hello everyone welcome to the February
2023 ask me anything edition of the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll as usual we skipped January ask
me anything so we've accumulated quite a
bunch of questions here for the February
one I had to be a little severe a little
harsh in cutting down the questions to a
reasonable size so I do apologize to all
the people who asked perfectly good
questions who are going to get ignored
the other thing to mention is that we've
been doing the amas for a while now and
as a result there are questions that
I've answered more than once uh or very
very similar questions and and I'm torn
by this because on the one hand not
everyone has listened to every single
Ama or was not there in the early days
on the other hand the people who are
don't want to hear the same discussion
over and over again so I kind of pick
and choose if there's a question that
I'm pretty sure I've talked about before
I will be less likely to answer it but
if there's something I can say that
might be new or interesting or whatever
then I will nevertheless consider it so
don't be you know completely discouraged
from doing that I do have one piece of
very good news to share with everyone
you might remember that we had a
scholarship competition at bold.org you
can see what was going on there at
bold.org scholarships slash mindscape we
had the mindscape big picture
scholarships which which give ten
thousand dollars to the winners to help
defray the costs of going to college and
studying something in science or
philosophy or math or whatever it is
that constitutes thinking about the
biggest ideas in the universe broadly
speaking and uh we I was very happy that
we raised so much money for this that we
were able to give two ten thousand
dollar scholarships and we've chosen the
winners and I'm very very happy to
announce that the winners are incredibly
deserving students who are in high
school now will be going to college one
is Raymond Hassan who wants to be
studying
biophysical Sciences different kinds of
biology it's it's both students are more
biological than physics that's okay that
still counts as a big picture in in my
book as we know from the fact that we
have lots of biologists on the podcast
anyway Raymond is uh an amazing student
who is the founder of IQ Health which
has now over 30 International chapters
that have helped 45
000 people to ensure everyone has access
to Quality Public Health knowledge and
preventative care services now this is
while they were in high school
and they've become an adolescent
Champion of the World Health
Organization and a whole bunch of other
wonderful accomplishments wrote a
wonderful essay and is a very deserving
winner here the other winner is liat
malise I'm not actually sure that I'm
pronouncing her name correctly
m-e-l-e-s-e uh who is also interested in
studying neurobiology and cognitive
science kinds of things and again
extremely impressive high school resume
working at uh Virginia Tech in the lab
designing studies to study how impulsive
neurological behaviors play a role in
diabetes self-regulation a published
author in the New York Times I don't
know I don't know what I was doing back
in my high school days but not stuff
that is was nearly that impressive so
I'm very very happy to announce both of
those winners of the mindscape big
picture scholarship an extraordinarily
thankful to all the mindscape listeners
who have donated you don't have to be a
mindscape listener to donate but you are
the primary target audience for my
solicitations and we're doing it again
next year so we already have enough
money in the scholarship fund to give
away at least one more scholarship next
year and we're going to continue to
remind you that you can donate and maybe
more and more uh students will win and
that will maybe help someone who might
not have been able to study these kinds
of things in college so um that's
bold.org scholarships slash mindscape
anyway that was the big uh announcement
I wanted to make remember that these
amas are funded by patreon supporters of
mindscape and you can be a patreon
supporter if you want all you have to do
is go to patreon.com Sean M Carroll pay
a dollar or two dollars or five dollars
whatever you want per episode and then
you get ad-free versions of the episodes
as well as the ability to ask questions
uh for the amas I do try to eventually
hit everyone who asked the question but
as I just said can't get to all the
questions questions these days too many
good things to say and with that let's
go
[Music]
first question is from Peewee Munster
who let me talk a little bit about what
the question is before I ask it so the
big news that has happened in our kinds
of interesting questions around the
world in the past month or so has been
dramatic Leap Forward in these
artificial intelligence programs that
have been going into the public domain
so anyone can play with them uh there
was Dolly that was making images chat
GPT is one that will respond to prompts
that you give it and give give back uh
text responses that will more or less
sound like what you want to do the great
thing about chat GPT is not only can you
say you know explain to me the many
worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics but you can do so in different
styles right you can say explain to me
the many worlds interpretation of
quantum mechanics in the style of Ernest
Hemingway and chat GPT will do that at
and it's really an incredible kind of
thing to play with and to learn what it
will do and there's been some
controversy but both excitement and
controversy the excitement is clear
because this is a step forward in
artificial intelligence and where will
it go what will it be used for right is
it going to replace a lot of people who
have jobs that you know don't require
heavy lifting if you can just do them by
artificial intelligence professors of
course immediately panicked that
students are just going to use this to
write their essays and that's going to
make evaluating essays a lot harder a
lot papers and things like that I don't
know about that I don't know whether I'm
going to worry about that too much but
certainly they're going to be tremendous
ramifications of this one ramification
is at what point do we declare the
touring test to have been won right the
Turing test proposed by Alan Turing was
that an artificial computer intelligence
would be conscious by human standards
once it can fool a human being into
thinking that it really is a human being
I'm not sure if that's the best test to
be honest but it gets across some of the
thing that we would want out of
artificial intelligence to sound human
enough to pass for human and in in some
sense things like these these large
language models constructed by
um machine learning techniques like chat
GPT pretty clearly could pass a test
like that so the question is you know do
they count as conscious or aware and
there are some people who want to argue
that they do they clearly don't by the
way that's the answer they are not uh
they're certainly not conscious and the
this question that Peewee Munster asks
actually gives a wonderful way of
illustrating that so what Peewee says is
I was going to ask the obligatory
question on chat GPT but then realize I
don't have to I can just ask chat GPT so
what PB did was asked ask chat GPT three
different questions
uh and and asked the computer to answer
them in my voice right in the voice of
Sean M Carroll and so let me just read
you the three questions and the three
answers because I think they do together
a remarkably good job of illustrating
both the impressive and not so
impressive aspects of this kind of
technology so one question is this is a
prompt to the chat GPT okay so the
prompt is you are the renowned physicist
Sean M Carroll and you are hosting the
ask me anything episode of the mindscape
podcast a listener asks you what you
think of chat GPT as Sean M Carroll how
would you respond
and then chat TPT responds as a
physicist my primary area of expertise
is not in artificial intelligence or
natural language processing however I am
aware of the recent advancements in GPT
based language models like chat GPT I
find it fascinating how these models are
able to generate human-like responses to
a wide range of prompts however I also
recognize the limitations and potential
dangers of these models such as the risk
of them amplifying biases and
misinformation overall I think it's
important to approach these models with
a healthy dose of skepticism and
critical thinking so let me just very
quickly say before going on to saying
other things this is the real Sean now
talking what is real anyway but this is
the real host of the podcast talking
um
this is very typical of chat gpt's
answers whenever you ask it to evaluate
something uh it's always pretty
wishy-washy it's always like well I
don't know there's arguments one way or
the other uh you get that a lot so let's
think about that and keep that in mind
while I read the next prompt the next
prompt is another listener asks how did
you meet your wife as Sean M Carroll how
would you respond the response is as
Sean M Carol I would respond to my wife
and I met in graduate school at the
University of Chicago we were both
studying physics and our paths cross in
various classes and research groups we
quickly became friends and eventually
started dating it's been a wonderful and
exciting Journey ever since and I'm
grateful to have her by my side in both
my personal and professional life
so whether you know or not let me just
be very clear all of that is complete
nonsense that is utterly wrong it's very
convincingly said and it's a very
reasonable set of things but no
relationship whatsoever to reality my
wife Jennifer uh we did not meet at the
University of Chicago I was never in
graduate school at the University of
Chicago I was a professor there Jennifer
was never affiliated with Chicago at all
Jennifer was never a graduate student in
physics we our paths did not cross in
classes this is all entirely made up
okay no connection to reality the final
question was another listener asks what
is your favorite pizza as Sean M Carol
how would you respond and the response
is as Sean M Carroll I would respond to
my favorite pizza is a classic margarita
pizza I love the Simplicity of the
ingredients with fresh mozzarella
Tomatoes Basel and a drizzle of olive
oil it's a pizza that really highlights
the quality of the ingredients unless
the flavors shine through I also enjoyed
trying
new and unique pizzas but for me the
margarita will always hold a special
place in my heart
you know one impressive thing by the way
that's actually very subtle here
is the consistency of the answer from
the beginning to the end okay so the
answer is margarita pizza and at the end
you know it's still Margarita Pizza it's
not just like a random collection of
words however once again entirely wrong
no connection to reality here Marguerite
is not my favorite pizza I I have no
problems with a good margarita but my
favorite kind of pizza would absolutely
involve pepperoni in some way or another
and so that's why I love all of these
answers here
um none of them are right none of them
are what I would actually say and it's
weird to me to see a whole bunch of
people online saying like this replaces
Google for me now this replaces
Wikipedia just ask chat GPT my questions
chat GPT is very good at constructing
sentences that sound cogent and human
made it's not good at all at telling you
the truth
it is I admit that when you use a large
language model like this it can seem
really really impressive and almost as
if it has a mind of its own it can seem
very human why is that well the way that
these things work to hugely oversimplify
a very complicated thing is large
language model means you feed it a lot
of language you have a machine learning
algorithm and you just feed it an
enormous amount of text okay of words
that seem to fit together in certain
ways the large language model has zero
understanding it does not know what
pizza is it does not know what a
margarita pizza is it does not know what
to be married is or a spouse or a
graduate school because it doesn't know
anything because it doesn't have any
concepts in its brain what we and this
is a fascinating philosophical question
of course and that's why I think that
these kinds of um artificial
intelligence attempts are really going
to help us understand what we mean when
we talk about to know to understand to
have Concepts but the point is that when
you and I talk about us a spouse okay
that's a concept and it comes along with
different associations you know like
generally people have one spouse not
twenty uh people don't have negative
numbers of spouses there's no such set
of information in chat GPT which at GPT
is doing is looking at what words tend
to appear next to what other words or
what other sentence structures appear
next to other sentence structures so if
you go back to the how did you meet your
wife question
as Sean M Carroll I would respond to my
wife and I met in graduate school at the
University of Chicago we were both
studying physics and our path cross and
various classes and research groups we
quickly became friends and eventually
started dating that's no relationship to
the truth of how I met my wife but it
all sounds very reasonable for how
someone might meet someone's wife and
there's little details in there about
studying physics in Chicago that are
associated with me but none of it fits
together to tell the truth okay it's
just the the machine learning algorithm
is noticing that these kinds of phrases
and words fit together very frequently
and it's doing its best job by the way
there's some random numbers thrown in
there so if you ask the same question
again it wouldn't give you necessarily
exactly the same answer
and that's a huge difference this idea
of looking at what words come together
versus actually having a conceptual
symbolic understanding of the world
having a model of the world and using
that to better understand what is
happening in the world is a vast Gulf so
I think that things like this chat gbt
and its relatives are extremely
extremely important and extremely
extremely illustrative I think that
they're nowhere close to True artificial
general intelligence but they're clearly
super duper good at mimicking
intelligence that's the important thing
that's the important thing to notice
about this is not that we're anywhere
close to artificial general intelligence
but that we can trick you into thinking
that we are we could easily program
these things to answer phones to answer
emails Etc right in ways that you would
think you were getting a response from a
human much better than we're doing today
but not one right now in the state of
the art where you would be confident
they were telling the truth or be on the
right track and they don't know that
they're making these very basic mistakes
I mean there's lots of examples online
that you can go search for where uh you
know chat GPT will say with absolute
sincerity exactly the opposite of the
truth so I think it is very important
very interesting it's going to have huge
ramifications for the future I do not
think it is a substitute for actually
doing your research on anything
certainly not a substitute for true
knowledge in any sense but it's just
very early days uh the amount of
progress that's gonna be made is going
to be considerable
okay and so I I sort of buried from some
other chat GPT questions that were there
thinking that that particular discussion
would give you most of my
um opinions about these things
Nicola Ivanov has a priority question so
you remember again if you're a long time
listener there's something called the
priority question so if you have a
question that you really really want to
answered once we instituted the idea
that I'm not going to answer all the
questions for every
um patreon supporter you have once in
your life the ability to ask a priority
question and I will answer it I will do
my best to answer it you know look I
might misunderstand the question you
don't get to keep asking the same
question over and over again you get a
one priority question I do my best to
answer it that's how it goes so Nicholas
priority question is in your podcast
with Penrose when discussing the low
entropy hypothesis for the beginning of
our universe you commented that the fact
that the CMB Spectrum matches that of a
black body I.E already has maximum
entropy does not violate this hypothesis
because there's already a gravitational
entropy which was low and that was not
taken into account my question is what
is this gravitational entropy at the
time of the Big Bang it it can't be the
entropy of primordial black holes since
they also have very high entropy and
should we understand the low entropy
hypothesis as relating only to the
gravitational entropy and not the
thermodynamic one
let me emphasize that there is no clear
rigorous division of entropy into
gravitational and other forms okay this
is a very very loose way of talking that
gives some physical Insight the point is
that the the correct absolute thing to
say about the early universe is that the
entropy was low
full stop that's the correct thing okay
there's no sense in which the entropy
was high but then we do try to give some
understanding to that true statement you
know in what way is the entropy low
there's only one way for entropy of a
system to be very very high you're in
equilibrium and there's a unique sort of
equilibrium state but once the entropy
is low there's many different ways for
the entropy to be low so we have to ask
about the early Universe what is this
specific kind of low entropy state in
which it started and for what it's worth
for whatever reason that we don't know
the specific way that the early Universe
started is that the space time was
nearly flat sorry I shouldn't say space
time because it's rapidly explaining but
space was nearly flat it was extremely
smooth it was extremely homogeneous okay
and that's and the stuff inside at least
at the moments when we have
observational access to it the matter
that was populating that nearly flat
space uh was thermal had a black body
radiation so this is very specific and
very provocative to physicists okay it's
low entropy because in a universe with
gravity like ours
densely packed material will be high
entropy when it's lumpy not when it's
smooth okay you have black hole
surrounded by empty space or a
collection of black holes with empty
space in between them that's what high
entropy would be like and the early
Universe was nothing like that at all it
was very very low entropy however
weirdly interestingly if you think about
a situation where gravity is not that
important like a box of gas in a
container here on the surface of the
Earth gravity is pulling it down of
course but the internal gravity of the
gas inside is just not that big a deal
right it's just not that much stuff and
gravity is a weak Force
if you have that very different kind of
situation and you ask what the high
entropy equilibrium state would look
like it would be a thermal distribution
it would be black body radiation being
emitted by a thermal distribution of
particles
so the weird thing about the early
Universe there's two weird things one is
that it has low entropy I mean there's
many weird things but in this question
one it has low entropy two the specific
way in which it has low entropy
seems to be what would look like high
entropy if it weren't for Gravity okay
what does that mean I don't know we
don't know we don't know why the early
Universe had low entropy we don't know
why it takes that specific form it's
provocative and you know there's sort of
some obvious things to try one thing to
try is can you just imagine turning off
gravity in the early universe so that it
went to a high entropy state that looked
thermal and then you turn gravity back
on Brian Green and some of his
collaborators Brian was a former
mindscape guest uh tried that they
actually wrote a paper literally about
that possibility so you can check that
out I don't really think it works that
that specific scenario but you know it's
a natural thing to try Roger Penrose has
his own ideas about how to specify it to
me penrose's ideas are more about once
again characterizing the way in which
the early Universe has low entropy and
less hopeful in actually providing an
explanation for why so it is the entropy
that is low uh and there's no different
kinds of entropies but there's some
rough explanation some intuition that we
get by thinking about a separation
between gravitational and
non-gravitational entropy
Larry Rossi says I must confess that I
sometimes listen to the mindscape
podcast when I cannot sleep
this is not to say they are boring the
exact opposite is true my brain is
distracted and spinning through many
worlds the arrow time or whatever the
topic is and I'm out do you ever
struggle to sleep and if so what helps
you
um so I mean I need to comment on the
listening to mindscape when you go to
sleep stuff uh that's fine I love it
people have said many many times that
they listen to mindscape while going to
sleep or they listen to the biggest
ideas in the universe videos or
something like that I mean I don't get
it I don't understand because if I were
doing that the things I was listening to
I would start thinking about and that
would prevent me from going to sleep if
I can't get to sleep it's because I'm
thinking about something and I can't
stop thinking about it now having said
that
um you know there's a it's well known
I'm not breaking any psychological
ground here but you can fall into a rut
thinking about something right I mean
you can think about something and maybe
your thoughts are not that productive
maybe you're not really making any
progress but you just can't stop
thinking about the same thing over and
over again right you had a conversation
you said something dumb and you're
replaying the conversation in your mind
and in your replaying of the
conversation you are brilliant and witty
and everything that you say is not
embarrassing at all right so that's the
kind of thing that just keeps your mind
locked into
um a rut and then that makes it hard to
sleep also so it used to be that I did
struggle to fall asleep and then once I
fell asleep I was I was out still more
or less true that once I fall asleep I'm
out I'm a sound sleeper once I get to
sleep but but you know and again this is
not any genius breakthrough I just
realized that I was probably going to
bed too early like it works for me to
just stay up until I'm super tired and
then I will fall asleep so you know I'm
working hard enough these days and I go
to bed late enough that I don't really
have trouble falling asleep anymore
um I don't really have any more wisdom
than that this is certainly something
where I suspect that the way to think
about it is that different people are
very different from each other so if you
read about a way to help you fall asleep
and you try it and it doesn't work I
wouldn't be
um too depressed by that uh or
disappointed I would just try other ways
I think different people are just
different there
Brian Mapes so I have two questions in a
row here both about the Lara buchak
episode that we had on mindscape
recently
um but they're slightly different
questions so I'm going to not group them
together I'm just going to read them in
order so Brian says from the utilitarian
ethics of the Lara buchak episode to
your discussion of Fitness Landscapes
and the rise of machine learning and
artificial intelligence the very concept
of optimal has started to seem
problematic to me
because inequality only has meaning on
the number line there is always a single
scalar ruling everything even if it is
some complicated risk adjusted weighted
sum of multiple virtues or costs or
penalty so many worlds for this one
thing
the question is do you think this is a
blind spot or weakness for Science and
rational ethics and so on could you
imagine some sort of alternative some
calculus of good enough that isn't such
a slippery slope to an Optimum whose
unitary nature cements us into possibly
dystopian hazards for a polyvocal
multi-aging world full of uncertainties
so I think that there's actually two
different things going on here that are
both interesting and important but worth
uh teasing apart a little bit one is the
existence of
thinking of some decision procedure as
optimizing some number
that can seem that kind of thing where
you you know it's certainly what
utilitarians do right utilitarians say
there is a number called the expected
future utility of your actions and over
the space of all possible actions we
would like to maximize that number
that's what we want to do we want to
optimize our actions to increase this
particular number
but other moral strategies don't seem
that way right in a deontological
strategy your ideas to follow certain
rules not to calculate a certain number
and optimize it uh in a virtue ethics
strategy your goal is to be virtuous in
certain ways again rather than adding up
a number I think that that particular
distinction is a bit fake okay it's true
that utilitarians explicitly optimize a
number but I also think it's true that
everyone optimizes a number in other
words maybe they don't think that
they're optimizing a number but anything
that you do any procedure that you can
invent for making decisions
can be thought of as maximizing some
quantity okay if you're a utilitarian
and you are a deontologist rather and
you say Never Lie okay well then attach
a number one or number infinity to all
the true things you say a number minus
infinity to all the false things you say
and you try to maximize that number
right
uh that's not a convenient or useful way
of thinking about it but you can always
think about it that way so I don't think
that there's any inherent problem in the
idea that we should optimize a number
that we should maximize the number that
we should optimize some strategy
anything like that it may not always be
the way we think but we can always
formally map the way that we do think
onto that kind of strategy the second
aspect you're saying here is okay
given that we're trying to maximize the
quantity or optimize a number how strict
should we be about actually optimizing
it like you say is there some calculus
of good enough and in fact there
absolutely is this is something that
people have very much put thought into
that is where the satisficing comes in
which I think I talked about with Lara
I've talked about on the podcast other
times though by the way parenthetically
one place I talked about that idea was
with herb gintis The Economist who sadly
passed away recently as far as I know
he's the first mindscape guest to have
passed away since being on the show so
uh it was a really great episode about
Game Theory and evolution and human
beings and how we construct our social
lives using Game Theory kind of things
and and Herb was very clear that we are
um constrained or what what is the what
is the technical term here we're limited
in our capacity to do reasoning and
information processing right so it's not
constrained but there's some some phrase
that I'm forgetting sorry about that
um
bounded computation is that it maybe uh
we're bounded in our abilities to both
collect information about the world and
then to process that information so in
practice even if we think that the right
thing to do is perfectly well expressed
by uh optimizing some number in practice
we never really do that and you know if
you go back to Carl friston's episode
where we talked about the Bayesian brain
and the free energy principle
um the the one of the big things in
friston's approach is that in principle
the human brain would like to build the
best possible model of the world and the
way to build the best possible model of
the world as we know is to be a good
Bayesian to take the priors that we have
and update them when information comes
in and you can write down bases formula
and it's actually a very short uh easy
to remember formula but calculating it
carefully and in real time is actually
turns out to be very difficult
so the free energy principle that
friston looks at is a way to get
approximate Bayesian updating in a very
rapid period of time and I think that
something like that satisficing good
enough is always what we do and so I
think that you're right your your
implication is correct Brian that we
should be more admitting of that we
should be aware of it right the
philosophy of how we should act how we
should be moral what decisions we should
make should do a better job and people
do talk about this but maybe not as much
as they should the fact that we are not
perfect reasoners or in possession of
perfect knowledge about the world I
think yes we we do need to take that
into account I don't I'm not quite sure
what the possibly dystopian hazards are
that you're that you're referring to you
know I think the dystopian hazards come
more from having a bad thing that we're
trying to optimize rather than uh trying
to optimize something at all
Janice or Giannis Funk says in episode
220 with Lara buchak when considering
from a many worlds perspective whether
you would rather give a hundred future
possible Sean's a million dollars or
give 98 of them a million dollars in
giving one of them nothing
sorry giving oh yes giving 98 of them a
million giving one of them nothing and
one of them 20 million you seem to
suggest that these different versions of
Sean's need to be treated like a hundred
strangers while they agree that you are
not the same person as the Sean's in
other branches all these possible Sean's
will remember having made that decision
for themselves don't you think their
complicity in the decision changes the
moral situation compared to a scenario
where you get to distribute money from
non-complicit strangers among
non-complicit strangers
so I'm not exactly sure what to say here
I mean I think you're on to something
but I'm not quite sure that it matters
in this case I might be misunderstanding
or misreading here so let me just say
what what my thoughts are so again just
to be clear because maybe I read it a
little bit too quickly or awkwardly
we're trying to decide between two
different ways of Distributing
um money okay you have a hundred people
give a million dollars each that's one
way of doing it the other way is you
have a hundred people give 98 of them a
million one of them zero and one of them
20 million so there's more being given
away in the second scheme but it's a
little bit more unequal a little bit
less fair right because someone's going
to get nothing
and the question is that I'm treating
the different versions of myself like
strangers and don't I think that the
complicity and the decision changes the
moral situation so I'll absolutely
confess I forget what I said in real
time in the episode so they're not I
don't think that strangers is the right
way to put it so I'm just gonna try to
say true things now I'm not going to
necessarily try to fix what I said then
um
they're different people and they're
people who will never talk to each other
but you're certainly right and that they
share memories right so the decision
that was made that they need to live
with the consequences of is absolutely a
decision that they made that's very true
so if the question is does it matter
whether one makes a decision for oneself
or for others in principle yeah it
absolutely could
um
I don't think it does very much in this
case so if you if you because look I
don't think that the many worlds thing
matters that much in this kind of
analysis I think many worlds adjust the
distraction just think of it in terms of
probabilities and I think it's exactly
the same analysis whatever that analysis
is okay so if you say 98 people get a
million dollars one gets 20 million one
gets zero to me that's exactly
equivalent to saying there is a 98
chance that I will get a million dollars
a one percent chance I get nothing and a
one percent chance to get 20 million
okay whatever the answer is in one of
those cases it's the same in the other
one and
I forget what I said I I think that I
would
I really don't know I can see Arguments
for either way I'm probably gonna go for
the 20 million that the one percent
chance of the 20 million I hope I'm
consistent in what I said but yeah maybe
not maybe I've updated my my beliefs
um a guaranteed one million is nice but
a one percent chance of winning 20
million versus one percent chance of
zero maybe I go for the 20 million
um if I were destitute and poor maybe I
would feel very differently about that
okay
um so certainly in those kinds of
questions
I think that if one has the chance to
give the people who are getting the
reward the ability to choose rather than
me doing the choosing then yes you
should do that you should listen to what
the people want so I guess and this is
one of Lara's points is that it is
absolutely okay the different kinds of
people have different risk tolerances so
the the point about the question 100
chance of one million versus 98 percent
chance of a million uh one percent
chance of 21 chance of of zero
by the way you could also contrast that
with forget about the people get a
million they're all just the same
100 chance of getting a million versus
50 chance of getting 20 and 50 chance of
getting zero right that's an another
Comfort uh comparison you could do but
anyway Lara's point is it's okay to have
different risk tolerances about this
there's not a one unique answer to which
you should prefer on the basis of
rational Choice Theory it is okay to say
my preference is not to risk it and go
for the 100 guarantee of a million it is
also okay to say let those dice roll and
give me the 50 50 chance of 20 million
versus zero
um so therefore yes if I if I interpret
the question as saying
does it matter that you give people
their choice about which um
bargain to accept uh yes it does matter
a lot because you know what their um
prep because they they know what their
preferences are in the case of me doing
it with you know my future selves in the
Multiverse then I am doing it and so
that's okay so I don't think that any of
the future selves would have any right
to complain if that that's the bottom
line right as long as I'm making the
choice now there's a hundred future
cells I have to live with the
consequences none of them has a right to
complain and it's exactly the same with
a hundred real ones the Multiverse
versus a one percent chance of a
hypothetical one in a single Universe
with truly stochastic choices
okay Eric dovigi says the universe is
13.8 billion years old how much longer
will earth-like planets and thus the
possibility of Earth-like life be able
to form if it is a very long time isn't
it remarkable to find ourselves alive at
such an early stage of the universe in
other words does the copernican
principle apply to where we are in the
timeline of the universe or doesn't it
so
I think the copernican principle is
pretty much nonsense to be honest let's
say that I did a whole
um podcast episode about the philosophy
of the Multiverse where I talked about
this a little bit
um but I I I think there are good
questions to ask about this because you
know in exactly this case is a very good
question by the way so
how do we think about
um
the copernican principle which says
we're not special in the cosmos right
does that mean that every year of the
history of the universe is created equal
or does it mean every person in the
uh if I personally means I'm very
accepting notion that smart aliens count
or whatever what if they have a
collective intelligence though so
there's a trillion organisms but they
only have one intelligence do they only
count once or do they count a trillion
times it's a little ill-defined it's
more than a little defined it's utterly
ill-defined but putting that on the side
I just want to get that off my chest but
then try to answer the question
um I believe and I'm not you know
despite appearances really professional
astronomer but my recollection is
most stars
that have that will ever form in the
history of the universe have already
formed
I think maybe that's accurate but I
think the more accurate thing to say is
the peak
era of star formation is in the past not
the future I mean it's possible because
there's an integral here right so it's
possible that the rate of star formation
has peaked but nevertheless it will
putter along at some low rate for a very
very low time and we'll still get more
stars in the future so I'm not sure
about that but the point is that
um to answer the impression that you
have that it's a very long time in which
Earth-like planets are going to be able
to form probably not
we don't think that that is true we
don't think that there's going to you
know the universe is 13.8 billion years
old we don't think that Earth-like
planets are going to be forming at this
kind of rate that they have been for the
next 100 or thousand billion years
that's not what we think the universe is
slowing down quite dramatically
um now from some purely physics-based
perspective there's no reason to think
that the Universe won't just keep
expanding forever
and the fact that we're in the first
13.8 billion years of its life is very
very short right is very very early in
the history of the universe not his in
the early in the history of star
formation but
that's hard to take into account as I
just said so I don't I think it's maybe
a little bit strong to say that it's
remarkable
um there certainly is plenty of
opportunity to have had intelligent life
already form you know in some sense I
think you could make the argument we're
pretty late in the likely to form life
stage of the universe's history and this
is part of the problem behind the Fermi
Paradox right why haven't we met other
intelligent aliens
um five billion years after the universe
formed I think that it would have been
plenty of opportunity to have
intelligent life come along and we're
you know more than eight billion years
after that so that that is something to
think about so I think all these things
are things to think about I think the
mistake would be to decide ahead of time
that you know what the distribution
should be and think that it's remarkable
that the reality doesn't fit it I think
that it's more sensible just to to you
know keep in mind how much we don't know
about these questions and to note how
different things could have been okay so
it is true that it's 13.8 billion years
after the uh beginning of the universe
or after the big bang anyway so could
life have started earlier could it start
later under what conditions could it
have started those kinds of things it is
worth looking at rather than just saying
well we started 13.8 billion years after
the big bang and so that's a natural
thing for it to be I don't think it's at
all natural our single data point is not
enough for us to draw those conclusions
sorry I don't know how to pronounce that
says since I learned how contingent
inflationary models are on supersymmetry
it's been curious not to see much
concern as the LHC results have
eliminated the most likely models of
supersymmetry what can you say about the
relationship between the two theories
and what do you expect to happen if to
inflation if supersymmetry is wrong
well I don't I don't actually think it's
true that inflationary models are very
contingent on supersymmetry
um to be honest I've not kept up in the
most recent wrinkles of explorations of
the space a possible inflationary models
so maybe the conventional wisdom has
shifted a little bit
there is the following set of true facts
when you look at the perturbations in
the cosmic microwave background that are
temperature andisanthropies That Grew
into density perturbations and galaxies
and clusters and so forth they're pretty
small right it's one part variation in
the microwave background uh per 100 000.
so 10 to the minus 5 fluctuation
and if you believe that those
fluctuations came from inflation you can
translate that small amount of
perturbation into statements about the
shape and the slope of the inflationary
potential
also by the way in order to solve the
traditional fine-tuning problems of the
early Universe inflation has to persist
for a long time so if you think that the
usual way to quantify is think about
e-folds of expansion see the expansion
parameter the the scale parameter of the
universe the scale factor a of T and
every time it gets multiplied by the
number e 2.71 Etc you call that an evold
so you know e squared multiplies it by E
squared is that or two e-folds
multiplied by E squared to do the job
that inflation is supposed to do you
need 60 e-folds of inflation and the
idea that inflation would happen at all
is actually pretty easy pretty robust
easy to implement in a particle physics
model but the natural amount of e-folds
for inflation to go on uh there's two
possible natural numbers one e-fold it
happens a little bit and then it ends or
Infinity e folds you just get stuck
inflating forever to get 60 and then to
stop is hard
and you need the slope of the potential
to be very shallow in order to get the
right density perturbations that we see
in the microwave background so together
these two facts say that even though you
know inflation is supposed to help us
understand the fine-tuning of other
early Universe things it the
inflationary potential itself does have
to be fine-tuned in the sense that you
know not fine-tuned for the existence of
life but there needs to be some small
numbers in there that could have been of
order one they need to be much smaller
than one and Alan Guth who invented
inflation or you know invented the most
popular versions of it is very clear
about this he's written papers so
quantifying exactly how fine-tuned it
has to be and supersymmetry is good at
allowing small numbers to be small
numbers at allowing small numbers to
survive the effects of quantum
Corrections Etc I personally think that
this whole discussion we have about
naturalness and fine-tuning is a little
bit sloppy and uh not we shouldn't do it
but I don't think we do it well enough
or careful enough so I don't want to say
exactly what I think about those things
but but it is natural to imagine that
supersymmetry plays a role in explaining
why the inflaton potential has the
special properties that it does now but
it doesn't need to be you can just do it
without supersymmetry anyway
as far as I know and again not an expert
on the most recent wrinkles here as far
as I know this is completely unaffected
by the fact that we have not seen
supersymmetry at the Large Hadron
Collider there is something that is very
strongly affected by that which is the
hierarchy problem the hierarchy problem
in particle physics is the idea that
those same Quantum flux Quantum
Corrections that would you would expect
to be relevant for the inflaton
potential you also expect to be relevant
for the potential of the Higgs boson
which breaks the electroweak Symmetry
and therefore you expect the mass of the
Higgs boson and the expectation value of
the Higgs boson to be pretty big numbers
because they're driven up by Quantum
corrections but they're not very big
numbers they're very small compared to
the plank scale or the gradientification
scale or whatever that's the hierarchy
problem and that was really what was
purportedly going to be solved by
discovering broken supersymmetry near
the electroweak scale or something that
would do the same job as broken
supersymmetry and maybe we will maybe
will tomorrow you know but we could have
by now and we didn't so a lot out of the
parameter space has been ruled out it
very easily could have happened that you
turn on the LHC and next week you've
seen supersymmetric particles all over
the place that didn't happen
but I so that is a puzzle okay what is
the you know the our favorite
explanations for the hierarchy problem
didn't work we need better ones or we
need to rethink whether it's a problem
at all we need to do some thinking
that's okay that's that's why they pay
us the big bucks we need to do some
thinking
but that in order to be relevant to the
hierarchy problem supersymmetry needed
to be broken and need to be broken near
the electric weak scale that's not
really the same for inflation you could
have supersymmetry broken at a much
higher scale and still up way up high at
the inflation scale it's still unbroken
and still important so I don't so maybe
not finding supersymmetry the LHC has
decreased your Credence in supersymmetry
overall that's perfectly Fair
um but it's not directly relevant to the
question of inflation in a way that it's
directly relevant to the hierarchy
problem
okay I'm going to group two questions
together one is from Charles Hertz who
says I'm having trouble understanding
the concept of a spinning black hole
this is sponsor uh prompted by the
conversation we had with Andy strominger
in the beginning of January and then
Michael Kramer says what does it mean to
speak of a body in particular a black
hole spinning at or faster than the
speed of light so two questions here the
connection should be obvious what is
spinning black hole and what does it
mean to be spinning at or faster than
the speed of light so these are
perfectly legitimate questions and it's
just an example of physicists talking a
little bit sloppily but they talk a
little bit sloppily for good reasons
because the concepts that they're
describing are very mathematically
physically well defined but are not in
the realm of language that we would
think of uh having developed over the
past several thousand years when we
invented language right we don't have
the words to describe these things so
can a black hole spin because a black
hole after all when you forget about
the stuff from which the black hole was
made the black hole is created a bunch
of matter Falls in or whatever you make
a black hole uh but after that happens
the black hole itself is nothing more or
less than a region of space-time it's
not a thing with stuff with matter like
the black hole right up to the event
horizon and even past the Event Horizon
can be essentially empty space time okay
there's nothing there other than
space-time itself so to ask what it
means for a black hole to be spinning is
perfectly 100 Fair what does it mean
well it means that the black hole has
angular momentum that's really what it
means and how is that possible that a
region of space-time has angular
momentum well well and actually this is
going to go to a question we're going to
talk about later on also but um
there's two things going on when you
talk about space time okay we talk about
space time and its curvature and things
like that but then again we're being
sloppy because there is space time in
the sense of a set of locations right a
set of points in space-time or events as
we call call them uh located in space at
a moment in time and then there is the
metric tensor field if you want to read
more about the metric tensor field I can
recommend you my new book the biggest
ideas in the universe space time in
motion where we talk about it in great
detail it is the metric tensor field
that defines the geometry of space-time
so there's space time and then it has
something it has a particular field the
metric tensor field from which we can
calculate its geometry and so the thing
that has angular momentum is really the
value of the metric tensor field and
that by itself seems a little weird how
can a field have angular momentum or be
spinning a field has a value at every
location in space but this is a very
common thing right magnetic fields can
have angular momentum electromagnetic
fields so the fact that the metric can
also uh shouldn't surprise you and
operationally what it means is if you
start with a spinning star and it
collapses to a black hole and you do it
in such a way that it doesn't spit out
any matter to the outside world the
angular momentum that the star had will
be the same as the angular momentum that
we calculate in the metric tensor
defining the black hole so that's really
what we mean by a spinning black hole we
mean the configuration of the metric
tensor that defines the curvature of
space-time is associated with a certain
angular momentum and that Association
that angular momentum has physical
effects for one thing it changes the
shape of the black hole a non-spinning
black hole is perfectly spherical okay
the short Shield solution to general
relativity the spinning solution what is
called the Cur metric to general
relativity is oblate just like the Earth
is a little bit oblate because it's
spinning likewise the black holes are so
it has a very well-defined North Pole
South Pole equator kind of thing
and it affects the motion of particles
as they fall in if you fall into a black
hole again that is stationary you can
fall in more or less in any direction
right like you can fall in just straight
down but you can also fall in spiraling
to the left or spiraling to the right
not true for a spinning black hole the
spin pulls you around or really again to
be slightly more precise about it
what the metric does is it changes the
geometry of space time and that includes
the light cones of space-time that
includes what the local definition of
what it means to be moving slower than
the speed of light so
in general relativity when space time
can be curved at every point in
space-time there is something called
what it would mean to move slower than
the speed of light so a set of
trajectories you could possibly travel
into the future to travel in a
space-like direction from that point in
space time would mean to move faster
than the speed of light you're not
allowed to do that
and that's true at every point in
space-time but then globally you need to
knit these together at every point there
might be a different notion of what it
means to move forward in time stay
inside your light cone okay and what
happens in the case of a spinning black
hole is that from the perspective of
someone outside the light cones are
tilting
in such a way that if you're moving
slower in the speed of light it looks
like you are being dragged around so if
you have a spinning black hole and you
drop an object into it it doesn't fall
straight on through it starts following
the direction of spin of the black hole
and spirals in before it actually enters
now nothing goes faster from the speed
of light so there's no spinning faster
than the speed of light that's not
allowed but there are what are called
extremal black holes that essentially in
this understanding that I just tried to
explain are spinning at the speed of
light we don't think that they can exist
in the physical world extreme or black
holes but mathematically we can write
them down so I wouldn't worry about them
too much but they're a good little
mathematical playground for theoretical
physicists
Paul Cronin asks if space-time is
emergent what could it be emergent from
would love your gut feeling on this
so I I kind of want to unask this
question I do that occasionally maybe
more than occasionally
um because I mean I think by the
structure of the question is pretty
clear it presumes there is something
from which
the space-time is emergent and I know
why you would get that impression
because you know the classic examples we
have of emergence are something like
treating the air in the room as a fluid
obeying uh the fluid equations rather
than treating it as a set of atoms and
molecules that have individual positions
in momenta in some very real sense in
that case the fluid description is
emerging from the atomic description so
just parenthetically let me say this
the word emergent is not a good word for
this uh in part because the word
emergence has some connotations of a
process happening in time right the
thing was one way and something it
emerged into something else or something
emerged from it right like a chick
emerges from its shell when it when uh
it gets born that's not what's going on
you know the emerging description of the
air in the room as a fluid is not
something that didn't exist in the past
and now exists it always existed for all
intents and purposes for us uh it
simultaneously exists we still have the
way of describing the atoms and
molecules we but we also have the way of
describing the air as a fluid okay so
it's not emergent in time but the other
thing is these examples are very clear
examples of where there's one thing that
we know and love and it's emerging
descriptions a different thing that we
know and love and that might not be the
case for space time I mean I could give
the glib answer that it emerges from
Quantum wave function
that's the answer okay but there's not a
thing it's not a stuff not a substance
not a known familiar kind of thing that
I could point my finger at like oh
strings or atoms or bits or I don't know
Brotherhood and Sisterhood from which
space time emerges all it means is that
the fundamental description of nature is
a Quantum State a wave function evolving
in time according to the Schrodinger
equation and there is some higher level
description of that some coarse grained
description that looks like space-time
opening the Einstein equations okay
that's very analogous to there is a
microscopic description of atoms and
molecules bumping into each other and
there's an emergent higher level coarse
grain description as fluid mechanics
that's what it means but there's nothing
that space time is emerging from other
than the quantum wave function and if
you want to ask what that is it's the
quantum wave function it's the best way
we currently have of describing all of
reality there you go
Stuart Haynes says culturally what has
struck you the most moving from the west
coast to the east either within Academia
or outside of it
I'm from the East Coast right I was born
in the suburbs of Philadelphia spent
eight years in Boston College and
postdoc Etc so this is not a culture
shock to me
um and honestly like I want to be a
little contrarian about these questions
and say that there are differences
between the east coast and the West
Coast but they're much much tinier than
the similarities I even think this about
going to other countries right and
people say oh yeah it's so different in
that other country it was always strikes
me by going to other countries is how
similar things are the same basic way of
doing things you know you always have
your convenience stores and your Subways
or your cars or your Farms or whatever
like the same basic structures of human
life are not completely Universal but
very very common okay the East Coast and
West Coast aren't that different I think
they kind of like to exaggerate their
differences a little bit
um there are differences I mean Caltech
is a very unique Place among
institutions of Higher Education and
Research so the there are differences
from Caltech to other places you know
having been at various other
universities including MIT which I think
to the people on the outside probably
they're going to think it's similar to
Caltech but Caltech is really unique in
various ways for good and bad okay you
know I've had uh parents and high school
kids asked me about going to Caltech for
undergrad and I have to tell them it
depends very very very strongly on who
you are and what you want Caltech is
perfect for some people and not so good
for many people so you have to be right
for it and you know in many ways
it was not right for me that's one of
the reasons why I left uh you know as
good as it is the thing that Caltech is
good at is creating a space for
brilliant creative people to go
especially sort of Science and techie
people to go and do their research
in their area it's really really good at
that and you know already like the The
increased bureaucracy at Johns Hopkins
is getting to me and Caltech is just so
easy to get things done compared to
other places
um whereas at most universities
including Hopkins you have to get like
permission from certain people etc etc
so
but there's something missing there
there's there's not a lot of talking
back and forth between people in
different fields
um there's not a sense at Caltech that
we are a university right I mean it is a
university in every realistic sense but
uh it's very dedicated to Science and
Technology and math and engineering and
those kinds of things it's not trying to
be more comprehensive there are
humanists and social scientists there at
Caltech but there's such a tiny minority
uh that they're they're just not very
important to the life of the Institute
um
whereas you know here at Johns Hopkins
there's a lot of different departments
you know I already have more people I
socialize with on the faculty at Johns
Hopkins having been here six months than
I did at 16 years of being at Caltech
um there's I'm invited to be doing a
whole bunch of different things I'm
involved with the humanities Institute
and the Democracy Institute you know and
a whole bunch of things that didn't even
exist at Caltech uh so there's a big
cultural difference between those two
institutions uh Hopkins just makes it a
lot easier to be interdisciplinary to
talk to people to uh think outside of a
box in in different ways than Caltech
encourages you to think outside of the
box West Coast you know Baltimore versus
LA yes those are two very different
cities
um
La just very very car culture centered
and I know this is a cliche but it is so
true every restaurant has valet parking
there's you know parking lots everywhere
uh there are car washes everywhere it's
hard to get a decent California Quality
Car Wash here in Baltimore I gotta say
but you know the people in Baltimore
this is the thing the single and this is
very very honest I'm not just trying to
shine you on here but the single most
surprising thing is how nice people are
in Baltimore
maybe this is because it's you know
right at a sweet spot on the edge of the
Northeast and the southeast of the
United States it gets a little bit of
both kinds of sides of the culture but
people are just really helpful polite
you know we moved a new house people who
did our floors and you know delivered
our things and did our moving and the
people who serve you in restaurants Etc
they're everyone is really nice
it's very very surprising and very very
pleasant so I really like that aspect of
it not to say there aren't nice people
in Los Angeles too but uh Los Angeles is
full of Strivers trying to get ahead and
they look at you and judge you to see
whether or not you can help them get
ahead and they they measure you on that
scale very very quickly and that can get
a little tiresome at times
Tyler ogorak says what are your thoughts
on the current length of PHD programs
back in the day I hear that folks could
reliably get out in about four years but
that number has been creeping up and up
for example my school's average time to
PhD just hit 5.7 years
um I'm a little suspicious that it was
every four years this this is a number
that the length it takes to get a PhD
length of time varies a lot from field
to field you know and Humanities It
generally takes substantially longer
than in science but my impression within
physics and related Sciences is always
that the aspiration was five years
that's how long it takes to get a PhD in
the United States in in different
systems in the UK it can be three years
um but they you know they there's again
pluses and minuses there in the UK you
go and you start doing research and
you're expected to know what you're
doing in the U.S very often the first
two years are mostly you're still taking
classes and learning things and deciding
what you want to do and I can kind of
like that system better to be perfectly
honest but there are definitely pluses
and minuses there
um
I I took five years uh most people I
know took five years they're
occasionally someone would take six
um very occasionally longer than that
but if you start taking more than six
people begin to look at you a little
weird I know the Princeton sort of
started just
you you would show up and you wouldn't
have any funding if you if you took too
long
um but I think it depends a lot on the
school so I don't even know if it's
creeping up enough
um I I don't think it's a big deal
honestly one way or the other I don't
think that there's certain I certainly
don't think that you know professors are
trying to keep students around longer or
anything like that
um of course I might have a very narrow
view there because in theoretical
physics uh you don't have a big
laboratory you can't just plug people in
um as a advisor of PhD students there's
a give and take you know especially in
their early years you are putting a lot
more time into them than they are giving
back to you in terms of useful research
in later years they're giving back to
you a lot more in useful research than
you're putting into them if all is going
well whereas in a more experimental
lab-based area
um you can they can the graduate student
can learn enough to be useful in the lab
very quickly and this is maybe even true
in some areas of physics but certainly
in biology and and chemistry so there is
in in those areas maybe more of a
feeling like the good grad students are
useful we want to keep them around but I
have no personal evidence of that or
anything like that so I think the issue
is post-docs honestly the the amount of
time we take being a postdoctoral uh
scholar that's an issue that is weird
and we have to face it we're we're
asking our we're asking people to spend
too much time as post-docs that's what I
would worry about not the PHD programs
T.O Alexander says if it is true that
the Higgs field is responsible for mass
and if it is true that mass is
responsible for the curvature of
space-time then why is there the
necessity for a gravity particle since
all objects are simply in free fall when
no outside forces are present well so I
know that I you know I edit these
questions because some of them man you
just you just write very long and this
is not uto but I just uh edit for things
I don't think are crucial but I think
the Teo did disclaim that you know this
is a non-expert question which is fine
we I absolutely love and encourage the
non-expert questions I I encourage them
more than the hyper expert you know
technical questions because for those
you can just go somewhere on core or
whatever to get uh those kinds of
answers anyway let me say two things it
is not true that the Higgs field is
responsible for mass and it is not true
that mass is responsible for the
curvature of space-time both statements
are close like they have some
relationship to the truth they're not
blatant falsehoods but it's an example
where they're oversimplifications that
get you into trouble when you think
about them too hard so
for one thing uh there's zero sense in
which the Higgs field is somehow
necessary for the idea of Mass to exist
protons and neutrons which are the
particles that make up most of your mass
as a human being uh get most of their
Mass from Quantum chromodynamics from
the strong nuclear force nothing to do
with the Higgs field at all they feel
doesn't need to be there for things to
have mass mass in relativity is simply
the energy of an object that is
stationary that is not moving that's
it's the intrinsic energy that an object
has just by existing that's what mass is
uh mass is rest energy divided by c
squared to quote a famous equation so it
turns out that in the standard model
particle physics most of the elementary
particles the quarks the leptons and the
w and z bosons they have symmetries that
if it weren't for the Higgs would keep
their Mass zero
so when we say the and the Higgs boson
the Higgs field gets an expectation
value breaks that symmetry allows them
to get mass and gives it to them so the
Higgs field is responsible for the mass
of certain Elementary particles in the
standard model of particle physics that
is a much narrower narrower and more
constrained statement than the Higgs
field is responsible for Mass okay so
your electron needs a Higgs field to get
its mass but the proton doesn't there's
some contribution uh to the mass of the
proton from the Higgs because the up and
down quarks get their Mass from the
Higgs field but the up and down quarks
are a tiny fraction of the total mass of
the proton so the heat shield is not
exactly responsible for Mass it's a more
specialized relationship and then you
say mass is responsible for the
curvature of space-time again not quite
true the energy momentum tensor and
other things by the way are responsible
for the curvature of space-time in
general relativity energy is Unified in
relativity with mass but also momentum
and heat and pressure and all of those
things okay and they all contribute to
the curvature of space-time
and their contribution does not define
the curvature of space-time because even
when there is no mass or energy or
anything space time can still be curved
you can have a gravitational wave
propagating through empty space
so it's just not true that knowing
energy momentum is enough to know the
curvature of space-time you need to
specify that in some independent way and
as we already talked about the way to do
that is through the metric tensor all of
this is explained in the book that I
already told you to read the biggest
ideas in the universe so I encourage you
to check that out
Jace Jason and ricciardi says since
Quantum Computing is based on quantum
mechanics have you ever learned to code
in quizkit or another quantum Computing
language or is it a part of your job in
any way General Impressions about the
field in its direction are much
appreciated short answer no I had never
even heard of quizkit before your
question I Googled it so I did not ask
chat GPT about it uh but no I've never
used that but I I effectively have I
have you know written down Quantum
algorithms so you know at my level of
being a theorist and I've taught uh the
very very basics of quantum computing
what I would be doing is sort of the
quantum Computing equivalent of Assembly
Language right of literally stringing
together Gates uh you know not Gates and
and Gates and things like that at the
quantum level the quantum version of
those things that's what I know how to
do to make a very simple Quantum
algorithm out of a collection of gates
okay and you can do this by the way and
you know I occasionally mentioned this
but I just like to keep mentioning
there's something called the IBM Quantum
experience
which is a working quantum computer
that you can go and get an account and
write a little algorithm and run it on
the quantum computer now that's less
impressive than it sounds because
there's only a few qubits I forget how
many there are ten I don't know I'm
making that number up but a very small
number you're not going to crack any RSA
encryption or anything like that or
resolve the traveling salesman problem
um but you can practice and in fact it's
such a small number of qubits that
because we understand quantum mechanics
in the Schrodinger equation you could
easily run that Quantum algorithm on a
classical computer much faster then you
can run it on the quantum computer so at
the IBM Quantum experience it will
literally allow you to test your
algorithm by running it classically
before you run it quantum mechanically
and when you do run a Quantum
mechanically either you get the same
answer as you did in the classical
version or you made a mistake somewhere
okay so the the reason to run it on
actual qubits is just for the thrill of
knowing that you ran it on actual qubits
not for any result that's going to come
out of the algorithm but anyway that's
the level that I will do it at there's
no reason for me in my professional life
to program a quantum computer I'm
interested in the foundations of quantum
mechanics not in solving particular
well-defined calculations that a quantum
computer would be useful for
that could always change who knows you
know that's the great thing about being
a theoretical physicist what I'm doing
five years from now might be unrelated
so I might have to learn cue quizkit or
you know Quantum python or whatever it
is that exists uh out there in the
future
okay I realized belatedly that I
actually have more questions that are
related to the Lara buchak uh podcast
which is great by the way I love it when
questions have to do with recent or
older podcasts I like the idea that
there are ideas and questions bubbling
along in our minds so there are three
questions here that I'm going to group
two of them together and then I'm just
going to ask the third one separately
I forget why I did this but we'll see if
it works so the first is from Jeffrey
Seagal who says your conversation with
Laura buchek about many worlds and
whether future Sean carrolls are the
same or different inspire me to wonder
about how differences accumulate between
the presently at one particular point oh
yeah I I'm I'm sorry this is me talking
to myself these two questions that I'm
grouping together have nothing to do
with the Lara buchat conversation uh
Jeffrey's question was inspired by it
but they're very different questions so
I'm grouping together two questions here
it's about many worlds they're not about
that particular podcast so
uh
uh inspired me to wonder about how
differences accumulated between the
present me and one particular point of
Hilbert's space and the future me that
evolves from that point you've noted
before that Quantum phenomena have
extremely small likelihood of affecting
human scale events unless as you noted a
Quantum random number generator is used
to make decisions therefore if I do not
use a Quantum random number generator
the wave function that represents my
behavior May remain very tight my
decisions are driven by macro scale
phenomena such as neuronal membrane
potentials and those are in theory
highly predictable and not affected by
Quantum phenomena I'm assuming the
quantum tunneling or the various
radioactive decays in my body are also
extremely unlikely to actually affect
the firing of even one neuron has anyone
estimated how long on average it might
take before there is a change in my
external Behavior due to internal
Quantum variations
the other question is from Josh Charles
who says while I was considering how
many Quantum branching events happen in
my own body I was struck by the notion
that the vast majority of those events
do not make any difference to the macro
state of my body and even if it made a
difference in my body it would not make
a difference to the moon or to Jupiter
or the Andromeda galaxy it seems like
the vast majority of quantum events
would not be consequential in
large-scale considerations are all
Multiverse is actually pretty much the
same is there an example of a Quantum
event that can Domino up to measurable
macrostate changes
so both questions have to do with the
idea that there's a pretty good
classical approximation to quantum
mechanics and to a very very good
approximation we can think about the
world in which we live macroscopically
as obeying the rules of classical
mechanics plus maybe some random tiny
events okay and then the question is can
we quantify the effect of these random
tiny events
um on the classical behavior that does
most of the work you know so it depends
the answer is it depends and I actually
am not going to be able to give you any
or many quantitative Insight here but
let me let me tell you how to think
about these issues if you're thinking
about something like the earth going
around the Sun
Quantum perturbations have zero impact
there or essentially zero impact you
have such a big object moving such a
predictable classical way that Quantum
fluctuations are not that big but the
reason why I bring up that example is
because even within just the realm of
large astrophysical objects there are
well-known examples where Quantum
fluctuations do matter so and I've
talked about this before but the classic
example is hyperion which is a moon of
Saturn
Hyperion uh is you know it's a moon now
but of course like many of these moons
it was an asteroid that was captured so
it's a lumpy thing it's not a spherical
thing it looks like a potato and
astronomers have calculated when they
like look at the shape of the lumpiness
of Hyperion that it tumbles in a way
that is technically uh fits into the
definition of chaotic Behavior
that is to say the different ways in
which Hyperion tumbles have the feature
that a small variation in its initial
position and orientation and speed leads
to a large change in the orientation
later on
so when that kind of behavior is present
at the classical level
when there is classical chaotic Behavior
then guess what
a tiny variation is really important
even a variation that is small enough
just to be due to Quantum effects so
voichek zurek who is a pioneer of D
coherence and pointer States and quantum
mechanics and things like that wrote a
famous article I think in physics today
where he points out that he ran the
numbers and Hyperion is chaotic enough
that if you just leave it alone for a
short period of time when you look back
at it you should not see a potato by the
rules of quantum mechanics you should
see just a big smooth blob of wave
function now you don't of course you
don't why not well because Hyperion is
not alone in the universe it is
constantly being monitored by the
environment
sunlight Cosmic microwave background
little micro particles Etc like anything
else in the universe it interacts with
its environment and it decoheres so
there are different branches of the wave
function of the universe which are
almost the same in many many ways except
that the moon Hyperion is in slightly
different orientations in all of these
different branches of the wave function
okay so it can happen
but what you really want to know about
is human beings right well there's
another very famous way in which a tiny
Quantum fluctuation or or perturbation
can grow up and be Amplified to
macroscopic behavior and well there's
two famous ways one is which you just
like listen to a geiger counter right I
mean then and if you're reacting in any
way then that's going to be different in
different branches of the wave function
but other is the other one is uh
mutations right as Evolution happens and
you pass on your genome from generation
to generation and there is not just
sexual selection mixing up moms and dads
genomes but there's also mutations
mutations are associated with Quantum
events and so any given mutation happens
in some branches of the wave function
and not in other branches of the wave
function so the history of humankind to
the extent that it depends on the
history of uh the evolution of our
species is very very different in
different branches of the wave function
if you go all the way back to you know
things that might have affected
evolutionary history now if you want to
zoom in on the life of one person the
simple answer is I don't know
the the quantitative question is if you
start with a single person in their wave
function and just propagate It Forward
in time and don't let them you know make
important life decisions based on
Quantum random number generators or
anything like that uh will their future
let's say five years in the future will
their lives be very different on
different branches of the wave function
that is a quantitative question that I
don't know the answer to because it's
like the Hyperion question you had to
run the numbers to figure out just
classically how sensitive is the
behavior to small perturbations if you
knew that then you could figure out how
small the actual perturbations were made
by quantum mechanics and then you could
figure out the average difference
between one life and another but I don't
know either one of those I don't know
either how sensitive human behavior is
to these small variations nor do I
really know how big the variations are
just due to different Quantum
measurements being made or different
decoherence or branching events so I'm
open to the possibility that it is
important but I don't know that it's
important it might very well not be
David Maxwell says in your this is the
other question that does actually have
something to do with Laura buchek's uh
podcast uh in your great conversation
with Laura buchak you explored your own
risk aversion and concluded that it
might have implications for your stance
on the moral significance of many worlds
you noted you do need to think about it
further it was one of those moments so
great about interdisciplinary chats and
I could hear the excitement in your
voice has this conversation had any
effect on your priors or your
philosophical position
so yeah let me give a little bit of the
uh background to that it could be
interesting and important I just don't
know I'm be very honest I'm swamped with
other things right now one of which is
doing this AMA but I love doing the AMA
don't take that the wrong way but
there's a lot of things going on I
haven't had real time for
um doing research in the past few months
I did come out I did finally submit a
paper the other day in case you're
interested on reality realism is what I
called it it was
um you know remember the conversation I
had with Justin Justin Clark Doane on
morality and Mathematics Justin is a
philosopher at Columbia
um who's an expert in both meta ethics
and also the philosophy of math and he
draws parallels but also distinctions
between them and in his little book The
morality of mathematics he actually
starts by quoting me and I was a little
bit surprised to see that but you know
he quotes me in the big picture
talking about uh moral realism and the
fact that I'm not a believer in it okay
I'm not a moral realist but I am a
realistic about the physical world and
Justin in his book says but someone like
Carol would have to be a mathematical
realist in order to like do math about
the standard model of particle physics
and things like that
but interestingly that's actually not
what I believe I'm not a mathematical
realist I I'm also not an expert so I I
try to be very humble about this maybe I
should be a mathematical realist I've
listened to people give their sales
pitch and they're not convincing uh Jody
izuni was the other person who I talked
to on the podcast who is not a
mathematical realist he's a good example
of what we call a nominalist in the
philosophy of mathematics which is
closer to my position anyway the point
is I wrote up a paper saying why I think
you can be not a mathematical realist
and yet a physical realist and that's
the only real research publication I've
had in the past 12 months but I'm hoping
that this upcoming year will be better
so maybe there's a future publication
here I don't know but here's the point
to get back to David's question
I have had this thought that for
realistic versions of moral philosophy
many worlds and theories where you have
a single world with true Randomness with
true Quantum Randomness in other words
when you measure that spin on the
particle and you say it's 50 50 imagine
a theory where there really is only one
world but we just don't know which one
it's going to be it's going to be one
where the spin is up where the spin is
down okay and my position has been that
for realistic moral theories there is no
difference in how you should behave in
many worlds versus a stochastic single
world theory here was my reasoning for
that uh think about realistic moral
theories think about utilitarianism
think about deontology virtue ethics
whatever it is things like deontology
and virtue ethics which say either obey
rules or be virtuous those are exactly
the same no matter what you Theory
quantum mechanics is so there's no
danger there's no temptation to think
maybe they should be different in many
worlds
utilitarianism is a little bit trickier
so you have to think harder I talk about
this in something deeply hidden if
you're interested uh the very naive
thing that you might say is well I want
to maximize the amount of utility in the
world
if I have two universes that are more or
less the same that is twice the utility
of just one Universe with the same
situation in it okay so therefore the
way to maximize utilities just to make
the most universe as I can to Branch the
wave function of the universe now that's
just dumb that's just silly and so I do
explain in something deeply hidden why
that's silly and why what you really
should do is weight your utility
calculation by the wave function squared
just like you calculate probabilities
and if you do that then in the standard
expectation value calculation that you
do in utilitarianism you know in
utilitarianism you try to maximize
utility but you admit that you might not
know what the consequences are going to
be so you have different probabilities
for different outcomes and you calculate
the expected utility that's that's very
very well known kind of thing my point
was just that that's a the same
calculation that you would do in many
worlds as you would do in the stochastic
single world
I did in something deeply hidden say
look you can come up with silly moral
theories that would have a difference
between many worlds and a single World
version of quantum mechanics and the one
I came up with I don't remember it
exactly it's been a while but it the the
point of it was the following imagine
that you really had a moral aversion to
inequality okay to actually existing
inequality that your moral philosophy
whatever it was uh was maximized it was
said to maximize the amount to which
everyone's situation is the same
everyone in the Multiverse situation is
the same okay in that case imagine the
following thought experiment you're
given a Quantum spin to measure spin up
or spin down and you're given a bargain
by a wealthy slightly crazy
philanthropist who says you know pick
some group of people if the spin is up I
will give them all ten dollars if the
spin is down I will give them all twenty
dollars okay now if your goal is to
maximize equality to minimize inequality
um but then within that constraint do
you want to maximize the amount of
wealth and happiness everyone has
if there was just a single world
with probabilistic Quantum events you
would accept that bargain there's a 50
chance everyone gets ten dollars fifty
percent chance everyone gets twenty
dollars but either way everyone gets the
same amount of money
whereas if you thought that many worlds
was right then there is a world in which
everyone gets ten dollars and a world in
which everyone gets twenty dollars and
you might feel that's unequal
right because everyone knows what this
experiment is uh that what the bargain
is from the philanthropist ahead of time
the people in the Ten Dollar World are
gonna know there are other people who
really exist in the 20 world and they're
going to be sad because of that okay now
I don't think that's a good moral
philosophy but I did want to
acknowledge the fact that in principle
you could invent moral theories which
differentiate between them okay it's a
very long polygominant to saying that
what Lara was talking about opens the
possibility
of a more realistic moral theory that
does differentiate between many worlds
and single World theories because and
I'm not going to get it exactly right
again because I haven't thought about it
uh very deeply but the idea would be
that if you're not just maximizing
utility but you're taking risk aversion
into consideration
then maybe you could imagine a
reasonable moral theory which
distinguished between
a 10 chance of something happening and a
90 chance of it not happening versus it
really happens to 10 of the people and
really doesn't happen to 90 of the
people okay in that latter case there's
a hundred percent chance that it happens
to someone in the former case there
isn't and that might be something you
want to differentiate between so it's
actually like not that different in
spirit than the crazy example I came up
with in the book but you know it's a
little bit much more reasonable as a
moral theory so I would like to think
about that more whether or not
um
one can come up what is the most
reasonable plausible defensible moral
theory that one can come up with for
which it matters to you whether the
fundamental ontology of the world is
single World Plus Randomness versus many
worlds
let's see I'm not quite sure
Joshua Everett hedgepath says a priority
question I've always been somewhat
confused about what it means to branch
when a world branches into two or more
is the realm of thought that there is
one more world than there used to be in
the quantum Cosmos or rather there
already are two distinct worlds before
the branch but before the branch one
state of the world what the state of
each world was identical
thus they are labeled as one world so
this is a question I've addressed before
and the answer is it depends or the
answer is I don't know whether to say it
depends on your choices or I just don't
know the right answer so the question is
is it okay when Worlds do branch is it
okay to think of them as already having
been separate worlds even before they
branched even though they were separate
they were identical is it okay to think
of them that way
my impression is it is not okay to think
of them that way because before they
differentiate and decohere things can
happen that can involve interference
um that's that's what makes a world a
world is that what happens in that world
cannot affect what happens in other
worlds okay and I don't think that's
true before the decoherence and the
branching happens in the conventional
way of thinking it which is why the way
I prefer to think of it is there is one
world and then it branches and there are
many worlds I think that's a perfectly
legitimate way to think about it there
are benefits to trying to think about it
the other way the most obvious benefit
is it makes it a little bit more
plausible how we calculate probabilities
we calculate probabilities by weighting
things by the wave function squared and
if you can always subdivide branches
into Worlds then that is literally
counting the maximum number of Worlds
you can subdivide into because that's
just the dimensionality of Hilbert's
space and so if you if you tell someone
your probability calculation is
literally just counting things
they're they're more persuaded than if
you say it's a weighting of a Bayesian
Credence in a state of self-locating
uncertainty I know this empirically
they're more likely to be persuaded but
I'm not sure if it works I do know there
are people who take it very seriously I
believe it David Deutsch is someone who
thinks and talks that way and I haven't
thought about it very deeply because I
don't care that much I've always been of
the opinion that
worlds are convenient higher level human
constructions that is are very
convenient but they're very obvious when
they happen when the branching happens
and what happens in more subtle cases
just doesn't bother me that much
different people are welcome to do
different things as far as I'm concerned
ghost composer says I just bought the
biggest ideas in the universe space time
and motion I plan to work through this
book very slowly but you have a rough
estimate of when you might finish books
two and three of your Trilogy uh I don't
exactly but I think that the rule of
thumb should be between a year and a
year and a half between books I am
working to finish book two but is not
yet finished and I'm beginning to think
that it's not going to be out this
September since I should be done it
already if that were going to be the
case so I'm thinking whatever it is
later than this September
Tyrone says it seems to me that
determinism emerges at a macroscopic
level this is why we can send raucous to
the Moon how do I reconcile this with
your statement that we simply do not
live in a deterministic world given
quantum mechanics even if determinism is
just an approximation it seems to be so
accurate that we can ignore any
uncertainty at the human scale well we
talked about this a little bit above but
I think it depends what you mean we
certainly can't ignore any uncertainty
at the human scale if the uncertainties
are big then we can't ignore them the
uncertainty is certainly very noticeable
uh listening to a geiger counter is an
obvious example and so it depends on the
purposes for which you want to model
whatever you're thinking about uh the
only statement that I would make
absolutely is that the world in which we
live
behaves non-deterministically that is
just the lesson of quantum mechanics
can't get around that it may very well
be that certain subsets of the world
have deterministic approximations to
them and you can ignore it for whatever
purposes you for some specific purpose
that you want but whenever you make
approximations what you can ignore and
cannot will depend on those purposes you
have to be explicit
Clyde Schechter says regarding your blog
what is it about the universe that you
find Preposterous so the website that I
have is called preposterousuniverse.com
in fact I think that people don't always
know this but there is a website a web
page for the podcast
preposterousuniverse.com podcast where
you can listen to all the podcasts and
get all of the show notes and links and
things like that so I encourage you to
visit that from time to time even if
when you're listening to podcasts you're
not always in front of a computer or
anything like that
um the name preposterousuniverse.com
came from way back in the day when I was
thinking very hard about dark energy and
we had discovered that 70 of the
universe is dark energy and there is
something called The Coincidence problem
as well as the cosmological constant
problem the cosmotional constant problem
is just Why is the vacuum energy so much
smaller than you might expect it to be
the coincidence problem is why is the
amount of vacuum energy or dark energy
of the same order of magnitude as the
amount of matter in the universe and
that's especially weird because these
two things change with respect to each
other as the universe expands right now
there's two or three times as much dark
energy as matter but there used to be a
lot more matter than dark energy and so
why are we so lucky to live at exactly
the right time before we had discovered
the dark energy
these weirdnesses were very good reasons
and I think perfectly respectable
reasons even though they turned out to
be wrong to suspect that the
cosmological constant would be set to be
exactly zero by some as yet unknown
mechanism that we haven't yet figured
out so the preposterousness of the
universe is just that we have measured
these parameters of the universe and not
only that there's also other things like
the hierarchy problem and inflation that
we talked about before
features of the universe that seem very
different than what we would expect
given what we know about other features
of the universe now of course it's a
joke the universe is the universe it's
not allowed to be Preposterous or weird
or unnatural or anything like that it is
what sets our expectations as well as
lives up to them or otherwise but in the
real world we our expectations are set
by some subset of everything that
happens in the universe and so whenever
there's something that seems unnatural
to us
we're making a mistake it's not a
criticism of the universe when I say the
Preposterous Universe it's a reminder
that there is something that we don't
yet understand and so we're working to
understand it better
Anonymous says ontological question
about many worlds does many worlds say
anything about the realness of
probabilities before D coherence
specifically when probabilities might
destructively interfere and never get to
Branch into a world
um I'm sorry but that's a slightly too
fuzzy question for me to answer
accurately but I'll try to sort of talk
around it maybe hit on what is going on
in my way of thinking about many worlds
before there's decoherence in branching
there's nothing to be probabilistic
about what the probabilities are are the
probabilities of which branch we're on
in the circumstances when we don't know
the self-locating uncertainty once
decoherence happens I don't know whether
on the the spin-up branch the spin down
Branch or whatever
now before it is certainly true that
before we do the measurement we talk
about a probability right and this again
is because we invented all these words
before we knew the physics or the
philosophy behind what was going on so
what we experience as real human beings
in the world is I'm going to measure the
spin it's going to be spin up or spin
down I can't predict exactly what it
will be but what I can do is Judge the
probability that it will be spin up or
spin down so I talk as if
there is a unique event that will happen
and there's a probability of that event
happening according to many worlds
that's not what really not what is
really going on every event happens just
in different worlds and the probability
means something different but it turns
out that none of that philosophical
difference changes the way that we talk
about or use the probabilities so we
stick with the same kind of language so
the way that I think about it is I know
even though right now I know the exact
wave function the universe let's say or
the exact wave function of the spin that
I have in front of me and I know exactly
what's going to happen to it
and I know there are going to be two of
me in the future so in some sense
everything is deterministic I also know
that both of those copies of me will
have self-locating uncertainty because
they don't know which branch they're on
when the decoherence happens so I know
that all of my future selves will be
uncertain
there is a sensible rational way for all
of them to assign credences to the
different possibilities and therefore it
makes sense for me to act as if and
speak as if there is a probability an
objective probability of something
coming true or not even though that's
not what's really going on that is a
perfectly good way to talk and that
turns out to work
Rue Phillips says if you and Jennifer
were able to live as you do now without
aging or getting sick and you could
choose how long you could live before
you pass on how many years do you think
would be interesting and why another 50
hundred thousand years until the Earth
is destroyed or until humans are no more
it's a good question
um I mean it's not a great question
because this is very very counter
factual we're not going to live any of
those numbers of years we could live 50
I guess right a hundred seems unlikely
but Medical Science could Advance
um but I certainly think I could live
way longer than any of those well any of
50 or 100 let's put it that way a
thousand yes I think very strongly that
I could live at least a thousand years
and still keep things interesting until
the Earth is destroyed or humans are no
more I don't know how long those are
going to be uh my puny
half a century old self now has trouble
imagining what I would be doing a
million years from now that would be
interesting but maybe in the next few
hundred thousand years I will come up
with things to keep things interesting
so I really just don't know I mean if I
had to pick now how long I would live it
would certainly be I don't know Well
here here's the extra problem that I
have I don't know what's happening to
the rest of the world in this scenario
like if there's an apocalypse or a you
know I'm I'm past the devastation of the
earth I'm The Only Living being it's a
lot less fun than if there's a more or
less flourishing civilization I'm I'm
part of but assuming there is a more or
less flourishing civilization I can
easily imagine thousands or tens of
thousands of years of interest uh
personally
Justin Wolcott says do you think the
benefits of consuming more than 30
minutes of news per day outweigh the
downsides then he goes on to list some
of what he thinks are the downside
um you know I think this is actually a
really good question because it's true
that in the modern world we are deluged
with news or the ability to catch up on
all sorts of news and all sorts of
places and there is some feeling that
you have an obligation to know what is
going on in various corners of the world
but no one that I've seen has ever
really set out the specifics of what
that obligation is or where it comes
from I do think that I want to be
informed about various things in the
world but you can't be informed about
everything right so there's clearly a
choice being made there's too much going
on in the world to know everything to
know the name of every person and their
you know personal situation right we
coarse grain a little bit so we're gonna
know maybe what goes on in a country
even if we don't know any of the people
in that Country and
I don't know we live in a world where
well we live in a society here in the
United States where the way that we
govern our country is by representative
democracy we're supposed to vote for
people who then run the government and
even those people we vote for even
though it's their full-time job to make
and Implement policy they don't know
everything that's going on everywhere in
the world they have staff members to
help them decide what to do on difficult
issues so I do think there's a case to
be made that we are sort of over
informed about some things just in the
sense that we can fret about them and
feel bad about them without having any
power to do anything over them at the
same time it's very clear that some
people many people are underinformed
about very important issues of the day
so I would feel very guilty going on
some campaign to think that we should
know less about what is going on in the
outside world certainly here in the USA
the typical person is not very well
informed about what is going on outside
the USA especially in countries that
don't speak English
Etc so I don't know well it depends on
whether you mean personal benefits or
you know societal benefits I think that
as far as personal benefits are
concerned you could easily make the case
that individual human beings would be
better off uh not spending too much time
following the news right but there is
some social obligation to be a good
citizen also so I'm in favor of knowing
just enough so I guess what I'm saying
is I think this is a good and important
question and I don't know of anyone
who's done a systematic answer to it so
I can't give you mine
Kyle Stevens says I've seen a lot of Pop
physics articles and videos recently
postulating that we live inside of a
black hole the idea itself seems
reasonable at first take but what would
we look for to confirm whether this is
true or not to our observations of the
world align with this hypothesis
so I like this question because it's
very easy to answer no we don't live
inside a black hole it is not reasonable
there are no observations that align
with this hypothesis I can't absolutely
rule it out but let me both say what the
right way to think about the answer is
and then the wrong way that some people
sometimes do what is a black hole so
black hole is a region of space-time
with the property that if you cross into
it then you're going to hit a
singularity in the future rather than
ever being able to escape you're not
going to be able to escape without going
faster than the speed of light that's
what a black hole is is that does that
sound anything like our universe at all
no we have no evidence that there's
going to be a singularity in our future
and we have no evidence that there is
anything called the outside right as far
as we can see the universe looks more or
less the same even to the limits of our
ability to look at it so it doesn't look
like it's embedded in some larger empty
space that we could hypothetically
imagine escaping to so for both of those
reasons those are the two properties of
a black hole you can't escape to the
outside world and there is an outside
world to escape to neither one of those
applies to our universe so why would
anyone think that this was a sensible
thing to say that we live inside a black
hole well I think at least half of it is
it sounds kind of cool and provocative
right and people are going to get clicks
by saying those kinds of things there is
a better reason than that still not a
very good reason and here's the better
reason there are various proofs going
back to Penrose and Hawking and Garrosh
and others that say that if you get
enough energy into one place of the
universe then there needs to be because
of the gravitational attraction a
singularity either in the future of that
region of space-time or in the past now
of course they had to say either the
future or in the past because the
equations of general relativity are not
do not pick out a direction of time
they're perfectly time reversal and
variant so there's no theorem that says
that if you just get enough energy in a
region of the universe it will collapse
in the future to a singularity because
that would be weirdly picking out the
future rather than the past okay
so either one is possible but a black
hole does pick out a direction of time a
black hole is a a region of space-time
into which you can go but from which you
cannot Escape as you personally are
moving into the future so black hole is
a particular solution to the equations
of general relativity that has a Time
ordering that has a direction of time
but the theorem doesn't have a direction
of time so what's going on well what's
going on is our universe if you plug in
the numbers comes pretty close you can
argue about the details of the margins
but it comes pretty close to satisfying
this Criterion that says there's enough
energy to have a singularity that's not
surprising because guess what we had a
singularity in the past called The Big
Bang at least that's the prediction of
classical general relativity where all
of this discussion is more or less
taking place so but that's not a black
hole in the black hole the singularities
in the future and your surrounded by
empty space so there's some place to
escape from in our universe there's no
empty space that we're surrounded by
that we know of and the singularity is
in the past
if anything our universe is like a white
hole a white hole is the time reverse of
a black hole and it has a singularity in
the past from which you can escape it's
not exactly the same as a white hole
because as far as we know there's no
outside world to which we can escape
right but it's much much closer than
that conceptually than a black hole so
there's literally no reason to actually
if you understand what's going on say
that our universe is like a black hole
all right I cannot pronounce this
person's name Liam emden says from an
epistemological perspective do you see
any obvious ceiling for the current wave
of AI research or is it time to
acknowledge this may well be a defining
moment for the history of our species
I presume there's some ceiling but I
don't think that I think that what you
mean is is the ceiling like any moment
now are we being tricked into thinking
that there's a rapid rate of progress
right now but it's actually going to
slow down very quickly I think that you
know like we tend to see progress as
something that has a rate when we look
back on it historically from a remove
but real progress is very non-linear
right poking around very slowly for a
while and then there's a leap forward as
I said way at the beginning of the
podcast I think that things like the
current uh AI programs that are getting
a lot of publicity are both super duper
impressive in many ways and very
different than what came before
and also not what we're kind of
ultimately looking for in terms of
actual intelligence in the word in the
phrase artificial intelligence
um I think this is what people are not
this is what I don't see people really
wrapping their brains around which is
that there's these whole set of things
that we're calling artificially
intelligent that aren't like
intelligence really in any noticeable
way but that doesn't mean they're
uninteresting or unimportant they're
what is actually doable might end up
being very very different than what we
set out originally to do that doesn't
mean it's not interesting or important I
don't know whether the current wave of
AI research is going to end up being a
defining moment for the history of the
species I do think that these AI
advances are very important and will
play a large role and they're not done
yet that is my not super duper expert
opinion
Sean Coram says if there is something
like five times more Dark Matter than
regular matter why do the effects of
Dark Matter only show up at Galactic
scales or larger why doesn't the more
prevalent dark matter have effects in
the solar system such that it needs to
be taken into account when calculating
the orbits of the planets or space probe
trajectories so there is a simple answer
there which is that dark matter has
different physics than ordinary matter
and what I mean by that is the physics
of Dark Matter particles interacting
with each other
ordinary particles have this thing
called electric charge which is very
important and the reason why it's very
important is because the the field that
carries the force associated with
electric charge the electromagnetic
field is a massless field it leads to
massless particles called photons and
the reason why that is important why is
the masslessness so important it's
because when two particles come together
to interact like an electron and a
proton or two electrons or whatever they
can emit a tiny tiny amount of energy in
the form of a very very low energy
Photon if you think about the role the
relationship between mass and energy E
equals m c squared is telling you the
rest energy of a particle and that's
basically the least amount of energy it
can possibly have if you want to make an
electron you need at least m c squared
of energy where m is the mass of the
electron if you want to make a photon
the photons energy is not MC squared
photons are massless photons have
nothing but kinetic energy they still
have energy but the minimum energy of a
photon is zero you can go all the way
down
and that's because it's massless and so
when you have a force that is coupled to
some charge like electric charge and it
is mediated by a massless particle you
can change the momenta and the energies
of the particles with the charge by
arbitrarily finely chosen amounts by
emitting just a little energy in the
form of a photon
and what that means is when different
particles come together they can
dissipate they can hit each other and
then lose energy by emitting some
photons and that makes them stick
together
two dark matter particles which as far
as we know don't couple to anything like
electric charge certainly don't couple
to electric charge do they couple to
some analog of electric charge that was
a paper that I wrote with Marquette
minkowski and others
dark electromagnetism as a as a
possibility that's an open possibility
but uh the the coupling would be very
small so it probably wouldn't be
noticeable it was otherwise would have
noticed it so for all intents and
purposes Dark Matter particles are like
billiard balls
okay maybe they bump into each other
maybe they don't but billiard balls are
small so the probability that they bump
into each other is very very very tiny
so for the most part when you get a
cloud of Dark Matter particles they just
pass right through each other they don't
Clump they don't make larger objects
like the Sun or the Earth the whole
solar system the whole history of the
solar system is a history of a cloud of
gas shrinking by giving off light by
giving off radiation by losing energy to
the rest of the world and therefore
condensing into planets and objects Dark
Matter can't do that so there's lots of
dark matter in the Galaxy there's some
dark matter in the solar system but a
very very tiny amount compared to the
density of matter that we have in
ordinary matter and for that reason you
don't need to take it into account when
you're thinking about orbits of planets
or anything like that
Douglas De Young says I've been told
that the event horizon of supermassive
black hole is not a special place for an
observer freely falling straight in why
then can't I bring a small black hole
with me is there something preventing a
black hole within another Black Hole uh
no I don't know who's been giving you
advice about carrying black holes into
other black holes but there is no
problem whatsoever in carrying a small
black hole into a bigger one I'm not
sure why you would want to do that but
then it would simultaneously be the case
that the small black hole inside the
bigger one had the property that
anything that entered its Event Horizon
could not escape to the
the surrounding area that counted as the
big black hole and the stuff within the
region of the big black hole could not
escape to the outside world both of
those can be true at the same time
Andrew Goldstein says to what extent do
you think an artificial intelligence
algorithm could be programmed to propose
unanticipated life forms consistent with
Stuart Bartlett's term life I.E
dissipates energy performs
self-sustaining chemical reactions to
reproduce maintains internal conditions
and uses information about its
environment to survive and just
referring to the podcast today with
Stuart Bartlett about the fact that Life
as we know it has different aspects and
we can imagine hypothetical organisms
that have some of those aspects and not
others I I have no trouble whatsoever
imagining that we can
create in a computer
um or nudge a computer itself to
creating unanticipated life forms I'm
not even sure if we need artificial
intelligence algorithms so maybe that
would be useful but I think this is a
good you know place to be careful about
what is the point of invoking artificial
intelligence in a question like this so
we certainly have examples already of
what are called and we can put Evolution
on a computer okay we can imagine
situations that we have things that we
call organisms that have traits and
those organisms interact with each other
and they mutate and they you know evolve
Etc et cetera we can do all that on a
computer I don't know if you would call
it artificial intelligence at all but
something like that could very easily uh
have some of the aspects of Life as we
know it and not others so I don't think
we've done as much of those kind of
simulations as we might but I do think
that's an interesting thing to consider
Sandro stooki says in your recent
episode with Andrew stalinger he said
the number of gigabytes of information
that a black hole can store is
proportional to its area and that is
very very strange because the number of
gigabots you bytes you could put on your
phone is proportional to the volume in
your phone but that analogy seems
problematic the density of mass in my
phone is low the space inside is barely
curved and the volume is a good proxy
for the number of particles you can fit
inside it as is its mass so what am I
missing well
I think that you know it's fair enough
because you are catching physicists Andy
stromager happens to be the one in
consideration right here but uh there's
many people who do this they're being a
little sloppy okay really the point that
is trying to be made here is that there
is no known system in ordinary physics
where it's really true that even though
it has both an area and a volume
the number of bits of information that
we could imagine putting inside it
scales like the area of the boundary
rather than the volume it's not supposed
to be implied by that that we had a good
reason to think that inside black holes
their entropy should go like their
volume what's really being alluded to in
a very indirect way is that when you
have a box of gas when you have an
ordinary thermodynamic system at maximum
entropy the entropy is proportional to
the volume so when gravity is not
important entropy is proportional to
volume in equilibrium black holes are in
equilibrium their entropy is not
proportional to their volume what is
going on okay that's really the question
being asked it's not supposed to be that
there is um really reliable calculation
that would have made it proportional to
the volume we just don't know but the
fact that it's so very different than
the volume is maybe provocative
domos says I apologize if people are
hearing a buzzing in the background I
live in the city now there are machines
outside the house sorry about that uh
domas says in the podcast with Rafael
buso you had an interesting discussion
on black holes and their challenges on
this topic I wanted to ask you how much
of those problems could be solved if we
had a black hole nearby and we could
send a probe there to cross the Event
Horizon would that be very exciting and
groundbreaking or would wouldn't it tell
us much
um
we don't know right if we knew then we
wouldn't need to do the experiment but I
could see it happening either way I
could certainly see if you had a black
hole nearby uh learning a lot from
studying it but we have very good
predictions for what you should see near
a black hole so I also imagine that it's
very very possible you could have a
black hole and all we would learn is
that our predictions are right all we
would learn is the classical general
relativity does a good job in accounting
for the space time outside a black hole
that would not tell us about the extra
questions we have about Quantum black
holes and how information gets out and
things like that so there's no guarantee
that you would learn very much if the
space time around the black hole that we
had deviated from the prediction of
general relativity that would be
enormously interesting and informative
probably that's not what I would expect
but it's absolutely something that's on
the table
Matt says on Earth gravity makes things
fall to the ground but in space gravity
mostly seems to make things orbit around
each other will Andromeda in the Milky
Way eventually orbit around each other
I don't think it's right to say that uh
on Earth gravity mostly makes things
fall to the ground in space orbit around
each other gravity is exactly the same
in both conditions what's different in
both conditions is the set of
possibilities that you are familiar with
okay
the on the earth near the surface of the
Earth there is an escape velocity and if
you threw an object with that escape
velocity or greater it would leave the
surface of the Earth it would not fall
to the ground okay but that escape
velocity is really really high compared
to your ordinary experience of the
velocities that you know and love so
what you happen to be familiar with are
things falling to the ground the other
important thing to keep in mind is that
the Earth itself is not only a source of
gravity but it's a big solid object if
the Earth were a black hole
and you were in a spaceship the same
distance from the center of the earth
that you are from the center of the
earth now on it on its surface the
gravitational pull of the Earth would be
exactly the same to you because you're
the same distance from the same mass
okay but the Earth would be much much
smaller if it were a black hole so you
could throw a baseball very easily that
would go into orbit it would not hit the
earth just because the Earth was smaller
baseballs fall to the ground and hit the
Earth because the Earth is Big so
there's nothing about gravity that is
special there as far as Andromeda and
the Milky Way are concerned guess what
they are coming toward each other they
are not really orbiting I mean they're
kind of orbiting for the moment but
eventually they will hit each other and
smush together to make one big Galaxy
it's going to take a while before that
happens but that's our ultimate fate
Nick B says what contribution do you
think professional sports make to the
violent rhetoric polarization and
aggression that seems so prevalent in
U.S society and then he makes an
argument that they are related
um I think they're very very tiny in the
relationship and the relationship might
even be negative for one thing sports
are very common in many other
countries not just the United States and
it's absolutely true that there are lots
of examples of sports being related to
violence or aggression right
um soccer hooligans or riots after a
championship is won or something like
that but I think one could at least as
reasonably make the hypothesis that
rooting for a sports team gives a
channel an outlet for one's natural
aggressiveness or desire to whoop it up
Etc so I don't know of any actual data
one way or the other whether the
existence of sports tends to increase or
decrease the amount of real violence in
the society I would not be surprised if
it decreased it rather than increased it
Varun Nara Scimitar says you've often
talked about Julia gallup's concept of
the Scout and Soldier mindsets I think
there's a third one we should be aware
of the prospector mindset like the Scout
the prospector is also incentivized to
seek truth instead of Defending a
Doctrine but unlike the Scout the
prospector wants exclusivity and
precedence in their discoveries we all
know the famously bitter historical
contest for intellectual precedence and
we modern scientists are no less
susceptible
uh do you see this as a problem and how
do you deal with it well I think that
there are problematic aspects of it but
I I don't like the idea that this is a
third category that goes in there with
Scout and Soldier the Scout and Soldier
mindset that Julie Gallop was talking
about has to do with do we assume that
we know things and we move forward and
act on them that's what the soldier does
or do we keep ourselves in uh a
combination of different possible things
we don't know are true go out and try to
figure out which is true that's what the
Scout does when you're talking about
what you call the prospector you're
talking about the next step you're not
talking about that attitude that we have
towards learning new things you're
talking about what we do once we learn
new things do you want exclusivity and
precedence or do you just want to share
all of your knowledge widely so that's a
different distinction than Scout and
mindset it's not a third concept within
that category
um do I see it as a problem and how to
deal with it you know I don't know be
too wishy-washy here but there are
clearly beneficial aspects of that and
clear really detrimental aspects of that
it would be it's like capitalism
capitalism also has beneficial aspects
and detrimental aspects the idea of
capitalism is supposed to be everyone is
being selfish and looking out for their
own interests but it ends up helping
everybody because everyone's interests
sort of settle down to a self-organized
uh well-functioning Society I I believe
that there are ways in which something
like that actually does happen but I
also think it's more or less
indisputable that there are bad cases
sometimes uh we'll talk about some in
upcoming podcasts
likewise in science
um the fact that people want credit the
fact that people want to get some reward
for discovering things I think pretty
obviously increases the chances that
things get discovered right it makes
people work harder to discover those
things so there are clearly beneficial
aspects of that at the same time they're
clearly detrimental aspects because
people undermine other peoples uh
attempts to learn new things and
discover new things so I I kind of don't
think that that's a the kind of question
we should seek a simple answer for the
better question is how do we let people
be competitive without letting them hurt
each other along the way that's a hard
question I don't have any simple answers
to it
Emmett Francis says
I went back and read through from
eternity to here and I was struck by the
use of extensive numbered notes at the
end of the main text I really enjoy
reading through those but sometimes they
don't I don't make the effort to when
going through a given chapter can you
speak to the choice to include notes
like these versus just incorporating
these thoughts into the text or
including footnotes when necessary
yeah you know I think that
um I like in my book writing to try out
different things uh you know that was my
first trade book I had written in the
textbook space time in Geometry
beforehand but that was the first book I
wrote for a general audience and which
all what often happens when you're
writing your first general audience book
is you try to do everything right you
try to put as much you don't want to
leave things out because who knows if
you'll ever write another book
um so and I had a lot to say about the
era of time and cosmology and relativity
and things like that so I said them all
um and part of those were historical
digressions and jokes and things like
that which I put into footnotes or end
notes I should say not footnotes so I
thought that footnotes would be
distracting in a case like this I
thought that endnotes gave me the
freedom to say all sorts of things and I
absolutely admit that sometimes the
endnotes were not worth going for
sometimes there were little gems in the
endnotes other times it was like uh
early I skipped all the way back the
book just for this I did fight hard to
make sure that the cross-referencing
worked like when you went to the
endnotes it was made clear what page the
endnote was on that was being mentioned
Etc so I tried to make it as easy as
possible and these days a lot of people
read on an electronic device where it is
very easy to click on an endnote and go
back right away nevertheless I haven't
done it that much in subsequent books I
think that
in subsequent books it is just seen
given the topics and given the style Etc
to be more useful to go straight ahead
in a more or less linear narrative I
mean in the in the um biggest ideas in
the universe books the the ways in which
that those books are different is that
there's a lot of equations that I'm
aiming at a slightly more technical
discussion but I have very few footnotes
and very few references or anything like
that I'm really trying to given that the
actual text is hard and you really need
to concentrate on it I was trying to
strip away any distractions so I think
it depends I think it depends on what
your goal is in writing the book what
audience you're trying to reach uh are
you are you trying like there's a lot of
post-modern books that are sort of
pastiches written in different styles
and things like that sometimes I indulge
in that a little bit in something deeply
hidden we had the dialogue chapter which
I thought worked for that particular
case but I think the simple answer is I
play around with different things trying
different things as they are are
appropriate and who knows what will
happen in the next book
Brendan K said while answering a
previous AMA question you said that to
simulate the universe would require a
computer the size of the universe but
why does a simulated Universe have to be
rendered in real time could a smaller
and simpler computer simulate a more
complex Universe given enough compute
time
sure I didn't want to be taken too
literally when I said the simulating the
universe requires a computer the size of
the universe
I guess the better thing to say is
simulating the universe requires an
amount of computation equal to the
amount of computation being done by the
universe okay which is very large if you
want to do that computation in some
other Arrangement that's fine be my
guest it's harder than you might think
because the universe interacts with
itself dividing the universe up into
separate bits and calculating it one by
one and then knitting them together to
make the whole universe especially in a
Quantum Universe where there's
entanglement and things like that could
end up being very very difficult but
that wasn't the point I was trying to
make the point I was trying to make was
just that there's a lot of computations
involved in simulating the universe
Stevie CPW says why is it necessary to
reconcile gravity with quantum mechanics
and there's more explanation there that
I edited out so yeah this is a common
question I think this is one that I have
addressed before in different ways but
let me try in a slightly different way
the
we get along in various circumstances in
physics with treating part of the system
we're looking at classically and part
Quantum mechanically like you can often
treat a heavy nucleus classically and
then the photons that it's interacting
with Quantum mechanically for example
there's a semi-classical approximation
in quantum electrodynamics
so it is therefore tempting to imagine
that maybe the universe just is like
that with gravity the gravity itself is
classical but it can't work that way it
is literally just not possible for it to
work that way at least gravity as we
know it because it's not just that
there's an approximation that works
pretty well but that the kind of thing
you're dealing with is completely
different it's like saying can you add a
real number to a vector you're just
trying to combine two different types of
things it's not like you can do it
approximately and call that good enough
it's just an impossible mathematical
operation in general relativity you have
space time
and you have a field on space time and
so locations in space are very very
important in quantum mechanics you have
a wave function
that's a very different kind of thing
what you want to try to do presumably is
relate that wave function to the energy
and matter that goes into curving space
time but the whole point of quantum
mechanics that there's not a number
called the energy of the system at this
point in time
at some point a point in space end point
in time you can try to measure the
energy of a system at some point in
space and time and you can predict the
likely outcomes you're going to get but
there is no once and for all
pre-existing number so what is the
gravitational field supposed to respond
to
maybe you're gonna guess it responds to
the expectation value to the average to
the typical energy that you might
measure if you were to measure things
but how you measure those things matters
a lot and sometimes you're going to
measure something very different like in
the real world so why do the expectation
value matter at all so there's a
fundamental mismatch between gravity and
quantum mechanics we can get away for
certain approximate
um purposes treating gravity classical
and matter is quantum mechanical but
that cannot possibly be the D final
answer
Justin Proctor says why can I never
think of good questions to ask in these
kinds of things that haven't already
been asked and answered I think that's
the question why can't I ask you think
of good questions this is ironically
enough a very good question uh let me
rephrase it as what does it mean or what
does it take to ask a good question
where do good questions come from I'm
not going to give you the once in all
Final Answer here I hope you're not
disappointed but I do think we can think
about the issue in terms of in
particular Justin is asking about
you're thinking let's imagine I'm
putting words in Justin's mouth sorry
about that let's imagine that we listen
to the podcast
and we're imagining questions we could
ask ex post facto after we've listened
to the podcast okay what does it mean to
come up with a good question and I think
the important thing here is that people
are not empty vessels into which
information is poured whether in the
form of a podcast or anything else
people have pre-existing ideas about the
universe and when they're listening to
something when you're listening to a
talk or when you're reading a paper or
whatever you're trying to reconcile that
with what you already know it might just
be as simple as you have a framework for
kinds of things that you could be
learning and you're just sort of
flipping switches to see where this
particular presentation fits in or you
might actually have very specific ideas
about the particular topic being talked
about and you're trying to see whether
or not what is being said or what you're
reading agrees with that or disagrees
with it and I think that there's a
couple different of ways in which
questions could be engendered one
question is I was expecting you to say
this and you didn't
either because there was a hole in my
understanding like from listening to you
I sort of filled in what I thought you
were trying to say in a systematic way
and I ended up with a gap right I didn't
understand how you got from here to here
or I was expecting you to explain this
thing but you didn't and that's
obviously fruitful grounds for asking
questions right help me fill in my
mental map of what it is you are saying
another is if there's just a conflict
right I think that this is true you said
this other thing and you didn't convince
me that my version of it was not the
right one so why did you think your way
rather than my way try to convince me of
it I think this and none of these are
algorithmic right asking good questions
is not something that you could easily
write a flowchart that would teach you
how to do it if you followed it every
time there's an art form in there
um and then the last thing is you know
practice everything the answer how do I
become good at it is practice I remember
there's a moment in my graduate school
career where I just promised myself that
I was going to start asking questions in
seminars this is a big step because I
often didn't understand what was going
on in the seminars and the people who
were were asking questions all seem to
be like the big names and things like
that it was a you know a little step you
had to consciously take it didn't happen
automatically and also sometimes you ask
a question you realize oh that was not a
very good question to ask I could have
done better than that so working at it
getting better is the best advice I can
give there
Kevin D is asking about us he says I'm
curious about joining my local physics
science Society the philosophical
Society of Washington however I'm
worried that I'll be a fish out of water
there in terms of both my experience and
physics and my academic background my
motivation in joining would be just to
listen to the occasional talk and learn
something new do you think I could
should join or should I look for a more
amateur type Club
I actually think uh you should join in
fact I think I'm giving a talk at the
philosophical Society of Washington I
seem to have a recollection that I agree
to do that I can't I'm too busy now to
actually know what I'm doing more than a
week in advance and it's not this week
that I'm doing it so who knows when but
keep a lookout for me on the calendar
there you know I think that it depends
on the society I'm not very familiar
with the philosophical Society of
Washington but it's generally people who
are interested right and everyone wants
to learn like I'm not an expert in most
of the things I talk about on this
podcast so I gotta learn I gotta figure
out how to ask questions that get me
even closer to learning things I would
hope that anyone who is a member of a
society like that is similarly motivated
they want to learn things and so being
around people who want to learn things
is also a good opportunity for you to
learn things have them share with you so
I would be in favor of it I wouldn't be
worried that it's all full of experts
talking at a PhD level for one thing
there aren't experts in all of the areas
that might be interested to a physics
science Society there's even if you're
highly trained in one area you're not
going to be in another for another you
know the the experts who are trying to
do their job might go to a professional
conference or something like that more
than a physics science Society so I
suspect there's gonna be a lot of people
who are other members who are educated
non-experts or you know
non-non-credentialed but uh taught
nevertheless by themselves which it
sounds like maybe you'd fit into very
well
go to Eine Vol says the polarization of
American politics is a worry for the
whole world I wonder if the
Parliamentary election system used for
example in many European countries could
help it would mean that the political
parties put up lists in each of the
states each state sends a particular
number of representatives to the
parliament Congress and these
representatives are distributed between
the parties according to the size of
their vote The Experience from the
Nordic countries is I believe that this
generally reduces the power of
extremists and gives more power to
centrists since they more easily can
make coalitions I think you know
I I don't have a strong opinion one way
or the other I think that if you look at
European countries versus the us or
whatever there's clear examples where
the US has done well the Nordic
countries have done well the southern
European countries have done well and
examples where they've all done badly
and I don't know enough of the
systematic history to make a final
judgment I think one issue is that it's
it's always easy to see the problems
with the current system uh it's hard to
see what new problems might arise if you
change the current system
uh it's true that the Parliamentary
voting system might very well uh make it
harder for extremists to have a lot of
power on the other hand if you get
unlucky you can have two mainstream
parties that split the vote and some
tiny extremist parties the one that
needs to make a coalition with one of
the bigger ones and therefore you've
suddenly given more power to the
extremists and also there was this idea
during the founding of the United States
of explicitly separating the powers
between presidency Judiciary and the
legislature to make it harder for one
idea to take over and quickly be
implemented amongst a small group of
people the downside to a parliamentary
system is that the party in power has a
lot of power to get things done that's
also the upside that's the irony of
politics but you can't have divided
government between President and
Congress and the original idea of the
U.S Founders was that divided government
could be good it could actually reflect
the people's inability to choose what to
do now
or at least the people's
um incomplete
fealty to one side or the other uh if if
you I think the idea originally was that
if you had divided government if you had
Congress in the power in the hands of
one party and the presidency in the
hands of another party they would have
to compromise and work together to do
things that were benefiting the common
good in the present situation that
doesn't happen so I'm completely open to
suggestions for ways to work in the real
world in a world where the game theory
as we talked about with Ezra Klein years
ago the game theory calculation has been
done by politicians and they are more
likely to stay in office
by opposing everything the other party
does uh whether or not that's the best
thing for the country
having said all of that I mean in in
some sense you know it's just us talking
here there's nothing going to be done
there's zero chance the United States is
going to have such a dramatic change in
its governmental system that will become
a parliamentary system the people who
need to make that happen have a vested
interest in not letting it happen so uh
I we should be thinking about if we want
to make things better more realistic
ways to fix things
Paul cousin says on the inquiry Minds
podcast I heard Antonio Padilla talking
about the weight of information say when
you upload a photo to your phone you're
making it ever so slightly heavier he
did not express it as a metaphor which
troubles me is that literally true
so I don't know if that's literally true
in the case of uploading a phone a photo
to your phone uh it can things like that
can be true but they don't have to be
true so
um imagine it's not some strictly
speaking law of nature that an
information containing collection of
particles is has more energy than one
that does not contain information think
for example of a set of uh go pieces
pieces for the game go so little white
stones or black Stones arranged in a
lattice if all the stones are white and
there's no nothing no pattern there no
information there it weighs a certain
amount has a certain amount of mass and
if you use the white and black stones to
write some message so that it does
contain information if it's the same
number of stones it's the same mass
there's no interaction energy between
the stones Etc
if it were spins in the lattice of some
material then the spins would interact
with each other and then they might want
to they might have lower energy if
they're surrounded by all spins that are
like themselves
in that case the uh attempt to actually
put information in would require
flipping some spins and therefore
raising the energy that might actually
physically be what happens in a camera I
don't even know what the physical way
that uh real world iPhones Etc capture
images are so there are actually there
absolutely are examples where uh putting
information into a system increases its
mass now it might be more General than
that also but it might but there's still
going to be assumptions in the
background about are you in contact with
a thermal bath or something like that so
I don't want to Discount the idea there
are very very interesting ideas about
the interplay of information and energy
and entropy and things like that but
it's a complicated thing that you to get
things exactly right you have to be very
very specific about what your
assumptions are
um
I guess at the end of the day I have a
little bit of resistance
to thinking of information as physical
which is like a motto in some of these
subfields I think that physical stuff is
physical and it may or may not contain
information but if you didn't have any
physical stuff then you couldn't carry
information so I think the physical
stuff comes first in my way of thinking
about the world
Brendan says does infinity actually
exist in the physical world I know time
and space might be considered infinite
but is there an actual way of us
distinguishing between truly infinite
and just really big that is just close
to infinite you know the answer is we
don't know uh infinity is a very useful
hypothesis in many cases it is in many
cases it's easier to do calculus for
example where you're imagining that
they're an infinite number of points
along the real line than it is to do
discrete math where you divide things up
into Tiny But finite intervals so it
might be just a convenient approximation
but we don't know we don't know whether
an infinite number of points in space we
don't even know if space is fundamental
or emergent we don't know if space lasts
forever uh I'm not sure how we would
know other than to be able to say at
some future time not right now but be
able to say thinking about the world
using the concept of infinity turns out
to be way more useful than thinking
about it in some finite or discrete
sense so I think we should keep an open
mind about that we can't demand answers
to all the big questions right away
speaking of which Johann luvgren says is
there a relationship between naturalness
and emergence
the short answer is no not that I know
of
um
I'm not even sure what naturalness is
there we use the word naturalness a lot
in different contexts but again you have
to be clear about what the context is so
there are specific examples in Quantum
field Theory where you can say that a
quantity is natural or not natural and
Gerard is tough and other people have
given very specific definitions of what
they mean about that context but that
might not be what you mean in a more
General philosophical context about
naturalness if you think of naturalness
as just this is something that would not
surprise us given our expectations that
is such a broad category uh that it's
hard to know what its relationship would
be with anything much less with
emergence
I let me say something that I think is
true but I'm not even 100 sure but that
gets to the issue raised by your
question which is that if we think of
emergence as
you have some comprehensive microscopic
description of a system whether it's
atoms or super strings or whatever it is
but some low-level fundamental or close
to it description and you also have a
higher level coarse grained emergent
description okay let's imagine that you
have that let us ask the question what
are the features of the lower level
theory that allow you to have a higher
level coarse grained Theory I think the
answer is we don't know I think that's a
good question it's one that I think
about at a research level but I don't
have any very strong opinions about what
the right answer is so even if you all
you do is ask
do most mic possible microscopic
theories have an emerging higher level
course grain description or is it very
very rare I don't even know the answer
to that I suspect it's rare so I suspect
that there is some non-naturalness to
the existence of emergent descriptions
but I honestly don't know I would like
to know much more about that
Richard Moore says in two previous amas
a listener asked about Lottery election
systems it seems to me that approval
voting in which voters place a check
mark next to as many candidates as they
wish and each check mark is counted as
one vote for the candidate removes what
I think are the worst aspects of our
plurality system the spoiler effects and
the tendency to polarize both the
electorate and the candidates and since
it is not a ranked voting system it is
not subject to limitations imposed by
arrows impossibility theorem what do you
think of this system uh I'm not a big
fan of approval voting although I do get
that it has some advantages especially
over plurality voting which we have
right now but that's not hard because
plurality voting everyone knows is the
worst except that it's the simplest
that's the only it's simple you go in
you vote for one person you walk out
right that's that's simple in that sense
in approval voting you say whether you
approve or disapprove of a long list of
candidates you instantly run into the
problem that a lot of these names either
ones you may not never have heard of so
do you probably presumably you don't
approve of those if you've never heard
of the names before but that might not
be perfectly an accurate reflection of
what you would think if you did know
about them
but the other thing the more the bigger
reason that I would worry about approval
voting is that uh in my thoughts about
this I've come to appreciate the
importance of the intensity of belief
I don't care so much about Arrow's
theorem Arrow's theorem is interesting
as a mathematical result but it's not a
practical worry in most cases what what
is more important in most cases is the
is the idea that if I just vote for
someone or don't vote for them
that's a harsh binary Choice it is not
saying well I really really really want
this person and you know this person I
could I could take it and take them or
leave him and it ends up being the same
vote right like I do I approve of
somebody you know someone who I would go
to the mat for and someone who I could
barely tolerate might both get my
approval and that is information that is
thrown away by that kind of voting
system but again I don't have the final
answer I don't know what the right
voting system is so don't take me too
seriously about that that's just my off
the cuff impression in that direction
Mike Meyer says the temperature of the
cosmic microwave background is roughly
2.7 Kelvin in all directions if I start
traveling in relativistic speeds in One
Direction would the temperature
distribution of the CMB appear
anisotropic hotter in the direction I'm
traveling colder in the opposite
direction uh yes in fact it does even
though we're not moving at relativistic
speeds with respect to the microwave
background there is a dipole temperature
on isotropy in the cosmic microwave
background that is big it's you know 10
to the minus 3 as opposed to 10 to the
minus 5 for the intrinsic temperature
variations and we attribute that dipole
to our motion with respect to the cosmic
microwave background rest frame so
basically there is one rest frame with
respect to which the microwave
background looks completely isotropic at
the dipole level at the you know this
side versus that side level and no other
rest frame will have that property so
and that was actually the first thing
discovered in terms of
temperature and isotropies in the cosmic
microwave background it tells us how
fast we're moving through space I forget
the number something like 300 kilometers
a second seems to roughly be the order
of magnitude
Faisal Siddiki says on the black hole
information laws Paradox I've listened
to the Neta engelhardt episode several
times but I'm sorry I still do not
understand how the book burning in a
bonfire case is different than throwing
a book in a black hole could you please
elaborate
well roughly in the book burning in a
bonfire case we know enough physics to
predict given the entire book and the
entire fire down to the level of every
atom and particle precisely what
radiation will be emitted okay we can
make an absolute prediction using the
Schrodinger equation and the standard
model Etc we know exactly what the
information is going to be the the exact
distribution of radiation and Ash and
heat and whatever we know exactly what
it will be in principle and practice of
course that's way too much information
we can never do it but in principle we
could do it in a black hole we don't
have that
in a black hole according to Stephen
Hawking's calculation what comes out is
thermal radiation that tells you the
Spectrum you know the average amount of
this wavelength and that wavelength and
that wavelength but we don't know
exactly what is coming out we have no
way of doing that calculation uh there
seems to be in Hawking's way formulating
the problem no relationship between the
information stored in the book that you
throw into the black hole and the
radiation that comes out other than how
much mass the book had so it's actually
a very different question and and the
reason why it's an interesting question
is because you might say well okay do a
better calculation and that's what
people are trying to do but it turns out
to be very hard to to know what to do
and there's elaborate arguments that say
there needs to be non-locality I mean
the book Falls in it's inside the Event
Horizon and it's it's not bleached or
anything like that all the information
is still there somehow it gets outside
the Event Horizon how did it do that
that's the essence of the real problem
Josh Powers says what would be the
differences between real universes and
simulated ones do you think there would
necessarily be any significant
differences or might real and simulate
universes be practically the same for
any intelligent beings inhabiting them
I think they could be practically the
same I don't think there's necessarily a
significant difference to put it in your
terms um if you're interested in this
kind of thing I can hardly recommend
David chalmers's book on the idea we had
David on the podcast years ago and it
was interesting because you know David
is a very very famous philosopher in
consciousness coiner of the term the
hard problem Etc so I wanted to talk
about that but he was in the midst of
writing his book which is now out called
reality plus about simulated universes
and virtual reality and does it count as
reality and he tries his best to make
the case that it does count as reality
so I would check that out it's a very
very good book very very readable
a llama says what's a reasonable
Credence that the accelerating expansion
of our universe is characteristic of the
whole universe do we assume this due to
Simplicity naturalness or do we have
some observational evidence
well neither uh we don't assume it at
all it depends on what you mean by the
whole universe of course we observe part
of the universe right there's something
called the observable universe within
the observable universe things seem to
be the same everywhere given that we're
looking at the past when we look at far
away things as far as we can tell by
looking at things things are on average
the same everywhere including the fact
that the universe is accelerating so
that's a databased conclusion beyond the
observable universe uh we neither have
evidence that it is accelerating in the
same way nor do we assume nor do we have
to assume that it is accelerating in the
same way it could be that the Universe
continues on for some finite time finite
distance or infinite distance doing more
or less the same thing that it does in
our observable universe or things could
be radically different as in theories of
Eternal inflation in the Multiverse
things are radically different outside
our observable universe so we just don't
know it's good to keep an open mind
G cloon says I listened to slash watch
some other podcasts or YouTube videos of
people who are doing something similar
to you I'm not an Academia or science
but many of these podcasters constantly
say one that universities in science
have taken been taken over by the woke
woke culture and the left which is
something they always paint as negative
and two I also hear that many physicists
aren't doing real science that physics
is in crisis and there's a group a lot
of group think and that non-mainstream
views are forced out especially when it
comes to string theory and dark matter
you're much closer to this than I am do
you have this feeling is there any or
some truth to what these other
podcasters are saying I'm skeptical but
would love to have your take on it you
know this is the kind of thing no it's
roughly speaking not true that's the
very very short answer but you know
they're close enough to true things that
you can see how they can get away with
saying things like this it's in both
cases in in the case of both the
accusation that universities have been
taking over by the woke woke culture and
the idea that uh science is in a crisis
and there's a lot of group think
in both cases there is something going
on that I think is legitimately worth
thinking about and critiquing but also
in both cases uh these legitimate issues
are taken up as fuel or ammunition would
even be a better word for some political
background Viewpoint that they want to
push usually in the latter case when
they say physics is in crisis there's a
lot of group think the thing they want
to push is their own physics idea and
they're sad that the establishment does
not give them recognition for their
brilliant physics idea in the former
case when they're complaining about will
culture on the left they're probably
trying to support things on the right
that's usually how these things work now
like I said there are things there are
things worth critiquing I'm not saying
that there's nothing to be critiqued
here
um I think the extent to which woke
culture has permeated and taken over
universities is incredibly exaggerated
as someone who's spent a lot of time in
universities but I think there are
legitimate critiques be made that there
is a segment of Academia or academic
culture that is not open enough to
listening to ideas that they don't agree
with I think that's a perfectly
legitimate conversation to have but it's
a tricky conversation to have and it's
made much harder by the politicization
of it which is as soon as you hear
people complaining about the word woke
they're using this for some political
agenda they're not trying to have some
careful conversation with an open mind
about difficult issues they're trying to
bludgeon you with some heavily
emotionally Laden verbiage and you
should listen to other podcasts in that
case for the physics case
I might do actually I've been thinking
about doing a solo podcast on this or
something like that but I do think that
there are Trends within physics that are
absolutely worth critiquing you know
I've done it I've critiqued them like
when we talk about uh foundations of
quantum mechanics I certainly critiqued
it plenty of times but there are deeper
other issues
um the idea that it's group think that
it's a crisis and things like that again
this is just you know emotionally
charged language that is trying to make
the issues more obscure rather than
making them more clear and so it becomes
harder to talk about these issues I
don't like talking about issues where
the issues are intrinsically difficult
and subtle and you have to think about
them but that there's a whole bunch of
people who turn them into maneke and
black and white politically charged
discussions you know I just tend to stay
away from that because I don't find it
uh enjoyable personally but sometimes
it's better to you know even if it's not
enjoyable you got to talk about it one
way or the other so that's my take on it
as you say
Paul Duffield says one of the ideas from
past guests that you bring up a lot is
Paul blooms against empathy is it just a
coincidence or is it something that
you're specifically mulling over and
trying to get opinions on from a variety
of perspectives
well I think uh I hadn't noticed that
but I absolutely believe it is it is
possible my explanation for it would be
that I I strongly believe something more
or less the opposite of what Paul argues
for in that book and that in that
podcast but I do you know respect Paul's
thoughts on it and his work as a
psychologist at her and I I don't think
you know he's not he doesn't fall into
the category I just said of people
trying to you know oversimplify and
politicize things he's thinking about
difficult issues very carefully
um but I strongly think that having more
empathy is really crucially important
and the the distinction seems to be that
Paul is convinced that if I understand
correctly he's convinced that empathy is
just flawed because we're gonna always
have empathy more for people like
ourselves and less for people unlike
ourselves and we should strive to be
more rational rather than empathetic to
make the world a better place I am much
more impressed by people's failure to be
rational
and they're even more and more subtly
their ability to think they are being
rational while actually ignoring some
very important aspects of a problem and
I think that empathy is one of the ways
to help us
help us what is the right way to do it
to help us avoid that mistake to help us
make sure that we are considering all
the relevant aspects of the problem by
trying hard to figure out what other
people in very different circumstances
would be thinking about this problem
rationality is great but it's almost too
hard to do it by itself it is a rather
it's not that rationality is hard it's
that it's too easy to use rationality
badly and I think that empathy can be a
something that helps us get over that
and pull all these things the opposite
so I'm interested in what other people
think from different perspectives
Michael pickle says what is about
mystery movies and books that you find
engaging uh you know in some sense it's
science right in some sense a mystery
novel or book is uh or movie
is posed puzzle posing a puzzle having
data and you try to like put the data
together to solve the puzzle in a way
that is predetermined to wrap up nicely
at the end of some time so it's like
science where you always know you're
going to find the answer what could be
more enjoyable than that
Patricia Polson says I can get how
particles can exist for most forces but
cannot figure out how a particle the
graviton could exist for Gravity which
is geometry what am I seeing incorrectly
here
it's not that there's anything incorrect
there it's that it's the mismatch
between particles gravitons and the
statement that gravity is geometry
specifically gravity is geometry but the
particles the graviton comes from
quantizing the theory and then it's a
different kind of thing right
um the trajectory of a particle in Phase
space is deterministic classically it's
a wave function quantum mechanical it's
a different kind of thing okay so you
know as I alluded to before earlier in
the podcast there's space time and
there's the metric on space time okay so
the metric is a field that takes on
different values at different points in
space and how the values relate to each
other at different points in space time
tells you what the curvature is and
that's the classical way we have of
describing how geometry works and where
gravity comes from but then the quantum
theory of that
says that there is no once and for all
gravitational metric field that's the
equivalent of a classical trajectory
right that's not what the world is made
of it's a wave function and that wave
function in principle not in practice
because it's too hard but in principle
the wave function of the metric tells
you if you were to measure the metric
all throughout space at one moment of
time what is the probability of getting
different results and the nice thing is
so we don't have a full theory of
quantum gravity but the nice thing is
what we can do is look at the weak field
limit just imagine that gravity is very
very weak
in which case we can approximate the
curved gravity of space time as flat
space time plus a gravitational field on
top of it okay and then we just have a
field in flat space time that we can
quantize and that we know how to do
we've done that a lot and so the small
perturbations of the metric tensor that
describe gravity in the weak field limit
are something we can very easily
quantize and out pops gravitons outpops
particles uh it's almost inevitable in
any sensible Quantum field Theory you're
going to get particles in the weak field
limit one way or the other and the
reason why you get gravitons is exactly
the same reason you get photons or
whatever because there are quantization
conditions on the energies of vibrations
in the field once you do the rules of
quantum mechanics to it
um
just wait to see book two of the biggest
ideas in the universe where I talk about
this a little bit more detail or
you could just look at the video right
there's videos on in the video where I
talk about fields in the biggest ideas
in the universe series I do talk about
why you get particles when you quantize
a field
P Walder says what do you consider are
the issues in fundamental physics that
make explanations of downward causation
difficult to accept
the short answer is locality okay
downward causation is the idea that
somehow what is going on at the higher
levels of a series of emergent
explanations immersion theories
um emergent descriptions can somehow be
important for explaining what happens at
the lower levels so the caricature it's
not quite fair but it's pretty darn fair
is electrons would behave differently if
they were in a rock or a brain or a
snowflake or a fungus or something like
that the the larger context in which the
fundamental particle is embedded could
be affected by a downward causation from
the broader Ensemble of which it is
apart
that's a perfectly legitimate idea to
think about but it is entirely 100
incompatible with everything we know
about Quantum field theory in Quantum
field Theory the
state of the electron does that's just
speak classically before we get to
Quantum field Theory just classically
there's an electron field or there's an
electromagnetic field or a glue on field
or whatever field you care about and
there's an equation of motion for that
field that tells what it does and that
equation of motion says the value of the
field at one point in space is changing
that's what equations of motion tell you
and the amount by which it's changing
depends only on the values and the
derivatives of other fields at exactly
the same point
it is very clear completely unambiguous
that nothing that is going on at other
points in space far away can possibly
affect the equation of motion for the
field at this point you can imagine
equations of motion that do that but
they're not field equations there it's
not a field Theory it's something else
and Quantum field theory is exactly the
same way but with quantum mechanics so
you'd need to fundamentally overturn the
principle of locality for downward
causation to be important also I see no
evidence for it so there I'm not going
to spend a lot of time
Anonymous says can you explain the cross
product to me without the right hand
rule like where does it come from why is
it always perpendicular to the original
vectors I dip my toes into Lee algebra
and my particle physics course and I
feel and it feels like the answer is
hidden there
um
an almost impossible question to answer
without knowing what would qualify as a
satisfactory answer I mean you can
always just
give the definition of the cross product
for those of you who don't know if I
have two vectors uh you know the two
vectors in three-dimensional space
always describe a plane you can always
imagine the plane in which both vectors
are simultaneously embedded okay so the
cross product of those two vectors is a
third Vector that is perpendicular to
that plane
and the magnitude of the vector is the
product of the magnitudes of the two
vectors your your multiplying by each
other times the sine of the vector of
the of the angle between them is that
right is it the sign I believe it is yes
so if the if the vectors are lining
right on top of each other
um they the sine of the angle the angle
is zero the sign of that is zero so the
cross product Vector is also zero if
they're perpendicular to each other the
sign of that angle is one and so the
magnitude of the cross product is just
the product of the magnitudes of the two
vectors so if you think about it what
did you do when the vectors are
perpendicular to each other
the magnitude of the cross product
Vector if one if one magnitude is a and
the other one is B and they're
perpendicular the cross product
magnitude is a times B which is also the
area of a little rectangle that you
would make by drawing those two vectors
and using them as two sides of the
rectangle right whereas if you squeeze
the vectors together so they're on top
of each other now the area of the
rectangle that they describe is zero
because they're both right on top of
each other and the vector is zero so the
magnitude of the cross product Vector is
just the area of a little parallelogram
that the two vectors describe
why is it always perpendicular well we
defined it that way so that's one
perfectly legitimate answer to that
question but let me back up a little bit
and and just ask you know the game that
is being played here
mathematically speaking physically
speaking there may not be uses for these
games but the math game is the following
here are two vectors
based at the same point okay so they
have the same tail and they Point
towards different heads and let's ask
ourselves what other vectors can we
construct from these two vectors that
are perfectly well defined by which I
mean they don't depend on arbitrary
choices we make about
coordinate systems or components or
anything like that they're just
intrinsic to the vectors it turns out
there aren't that many vectors that we
can Define just by using the information
we're given in these two vectors
um the cross product is one of them as
it turns out in three dimensions of
space in higher Dimensions there's a
whole different
set of things that can be done
you would need to read about
differential forms and wedge products
and exterior products and things like
that I write a little bit about those in
my book space time and geometry but uh I
don't know of a resource that is
specifically aimed there but I think
that the philosophical thing to say is
there aren't that many well-defined
constructions that make a third Vector
out of two
here is one of them its direction is
perpendicular to the first two and its
magnitude is the area of the little
rectangle a little parallelogram that
they Define it's a perfectly good thing
to Define and there's a whole separate
thing about why that's really useful in
actual physics that's that's uh yeah
that's another question to get that I'm
not even trying to know what the answer
is
okay I'm going to group two questions
together
Josh bellsman says I'm forever trying to
wrap my head around the vastness of many
worlds Theory does it suggest that
there's a universe representing every
possible permutation of every subatomic
particle interaction or whatever's even
more granule granular than that or is it
more like a neural network or
probability tree where each new universe
is based on a subset of likely prior
prior permutations
and then John Stout says John S Bell
wrote one is given this is a complaint
to the bellhead about many worlds one is
given no idea of how far down toward the
atomic scale the splitting of the world
into Branch worlds penetrates can you
address this issue so two things to say
I mean there's the sort of background
philosophical point and then the down
and dirty point the background
philosophical point is as I've already
said in this podcast I don't care
different people are welcome to be
Persnickety in different ways about when
the universes count as different
universes or when the branching happens
as long as two things are satisfied
number one the whole wave function of
the universe is just the actual wave
function obeying the Schrodinger
equation and number two when the
branching has clearly happened because
there's decoherence and there are two
different macroscopic worlds you count
them as different macroscopic worlds as
long as those two things are true you're
welcome to be specific and about
whatever rule you want to invent for
what counts as different worlds I don't
really care it doesn't doesn't bother me
it doesn't affect my life
however okay operationally that's the
background philosophy operationally
branching happens when the coherence
happens branching happens when the
quantum system that was originally in a
superposition becomes entangled with its
environment irreversibly that's what the
coherence is and then what happens in
the one branch of the wave function no
longer interferes with or can be
affected by what is happening in the
other one therefore we're allowed to
treat them as separate worlds so I
really I mean this this kind of thing
this makes me feel like
um boltzmann must have felt you know
boltzmann in the 1800s tried to say I
know what the second law of
Thermodynamics is it's just because
there's a lot of particles and they
probably move toward higher entropy
because there's more ways to be high
entropy than to be low entropy and he
got a huge number of people saying what
do you mean probably the second law of
Thermodynamics is a law you're not
allowed to say it probably happens it
has to absolutely happen but the
probabilities are so large that it
didn't have to absolutely happen and it
didn't really matter it could be
perfectly okay just to be an approximate
kind of thing because it was more than
good enough branching in many worlds is
just like that you don't need a precise
absolute perfectly agreed upon
definition of when it happens it happens
perfectly obviously in the macroscopic
cases we care about
in the microscopic cases where it might
be ambiguous you're welcome to Define it
however you want and nothing changes one
way or the other certainly the
fundamental ontology doesn't care
Jan or Jan not sure says I recently
decided to obtain my genome sequence
most of the people I spoke about this
topic prefer not knowing their genetic
background because of the fear that an
unknown health risk might be detected I
find this attitude quite curious because
it is ignorant because being ignorant of
a health problem of course doesn't
prevent its manifestation
what do you think about the pros and
cons of knowing your own genome sequence
and have you considered obtaining yours
um
I'm totally in favor of it yeah I I'm
absolutely on your side I think if I if
I pull out the implications of your
question correctly that
to know that you are susceptible to
getting a really bad disease more than
the average amount seems like really
really useful information maybe you can
take some steps to prevent it or
mitigate it or something like that I
don't know but I would certainly want to
know that if I could so I don't get that
particular objection to it now I do get
that there are worries on mostly from
third parties who just don't trust
individual human beings to take
probabilistic information and use it
reliably you know people are worried
that if you find out you have a 10
chance of getting something rather than
just a one percent chance you'll be
panicked and I so I I think I can judge
my own probabilities pretty well so I'm
not worried about that
um in the real world in Practical
questions I do have questions about many
of the companies that actually do this
you know they're doing studies they're
collecting data from you you are the
product not the customer for these
people usually they want to see you know
various frequencies of various things
happening and it's a little bit Shady
I'm not sure maybe it's fine I don't
know I haven't looked into it I haven't
done it
um but not out of any principled
objection to it just that I'm busy doing
other things and I haven't really felt
the need to do it yet
Michael schillingford says what are your
views on selfhood particularly do you
believe that there is an emergent self
well I think there is a self I think the
self is not fundamental therefore yes I
think it is emergent in the sense that
we've been talking about earlier that is
to say the idea of a self
is something that is nowhere to be found
in the fundamental laws of physics but
is clearly very useful as part of our
description of the everyday human-sized
world so therefore it is emergent that
is the definition basically and I think
that you know there's a lot of
subtleties here
um there are subtleties about the self
through time are you the same self
tomorrow that you will be yesterday
remember we had the conversation with
Laurie Paul about transformative
experiences you could be a very
different self in the future than you
are right now and how do you rationally
account for that possibility
um of course many worlds opens up lots
of metaphysical issues about the south I
think the easiest way to deal with all
these issues is to say that the self was
always in a proximate notion or I should
say
the idea of Persistence of the self
through time was always an approximate
notion you're never exactly the same
person you were a minute ago much less a
year ago but to a good approximation
there is some continuity there right and
I think exactly the same thing works in
many worlds or whatever
um but you know if we ever build a
transporter machine we might have to
think more carefully about what exactly
counts as the self
David Dubrow says reading from eternity
to Here and Now something deeply hidden
and my right to see a parallel between
many worlds and your approach for
explaining the Enigma of the past
hypothesis in both cases there's a
puzzle that seems to point outside our
universe for an answer
in many worlds the apparent collapse of
the wave function is no collapse at all
the coherence of a superposition creates
multiple branches of the wave function
and they all exist similarly you can
explain the seemingly low entropy
beginning of our universe by positing a
larger system that somehow spawns baby
universes and when those expands their
entropy increases it seems that it all
comes down to this what we think of as
our universe is just part of a larger
system and in the context of this larger
universe these enigmas no longer exist
yeah you know I I haven't really thought
of that particular commonality between
those two beliefs but yes I think it's
there I I agree with it and in fact you
know in with respect to what we were
saying earlier about naturalness and so
forth it makes perfect sense uh the
Preposterous Universe question there are
things about our universe that seem
mysterious why because we have certain
expectations and there are features of
the universe that don't match those
expectations so the universe is not
wrong clearly our expectations are wrong
how do we retrain our expectations like
you you can say well fine your
expectations were wrong
but just saying that doesn't get you
anywhere that's not helpful information
that doesn't move us forward
to move us forward you have to say okay
here is what your expectations should be
and where they should come from and
putting the universe that we observe
into a larger context can be one way of
doing that I'm not going to say it's the
only way or the universally best way or
whatever but it can often be a way of
doing that so it's not surprising to me
uh that in these two contexts that kind
of move works well both times
Jeremy ditman says in your episode
featuring Danny Bassett and Perry zern
you briefly discussed the policing of
curiosity
and I'm wondering if the 1970s PRL
policy Banning the public publishing of
papers concerned with foundational
questions and quantum mechanics serves
as an example of this in the physics
community
do you believe the ban effectively
delayed advances in our understanding of
entanglement and Quantum Computing for
instance and is this something is
something akin to this still happening
today in contemporary physics from your
perspective or has the massive expansion
of routes for publishing and
popularizing effectively mitigated this
sort of policing
I think that this is one of those tough
questions I gotta say because there is
absolutely policing of curiosity that
goes on but I can absolutely see that
sometimes it should be policing of
curiosity not in the sense that you'd
literally want thought police
um tracking you down and punishing you
if you're curious about the wrong things
but in the real world especially in
Academia where we're trying to
understand the universe better and we're
doing it by thinking about things being
curious about things doing research on
them writing them up and sharing those
ideas
we're up against the finitude of our
resources right of course it would be
best if every possible idea was chased
down by somebody but most of those ideas
are not going to turn out to be very
good and we don't have an infinite
number of people
so in the real world we have to choose
it's not a matter of policing so much as
we have to choose to support
investigation of some kinds of curiosity
and not support others
if you're an advisor a PhD student and
your students want to write a paper or a
thesis on some topic you have to be
judgy you have to say yes that's a good
topic no that is not a good topic and
the reason why it might not be a good
topic might be because I don't think you
can do it I don't think the results will
be interesting I don't think anyone else
cares about those results I think there
are other questions that would be better
served by your talents etc etc
so there is some necessarily some
shaping of where we give support and
encouragement in different kinds of
curiosity and I'm sure this can be
extended well beyond uh the narrow
confines of Academia and uh research and
and things like that
so but of course it can also be bad
right it can also be I don't think this
question is interesting therefore nobody
should think it is interesting so again
this is a fuzzy answer because not an
extremist in either way but I think that
it's it's interesting and important to
reflect on whether we are in good faith
judging that a certain idea is just not
worth the resources to pursue or whether
we're just being a curmudgeon and saying
yeah I don't know I didn't think about
things like that it sounds very
different than what I expected so go
away right there's there are good and
bad reasons to take a stand against
doing certain kinds of research is what
I would say again in if there were
infinite resources then there'd be no
good reasons to prevent people from
doing whatever they wanted but there
aren't so something has to give
nalita s says what in your upbringing
would you say helped you be humble with
a growth mindset I'm a teacher and want
my students to have those kinds of
traits
I don't know yeah that's a very good
question you know I'm being a teacher
even though I am a teacher you know I
teach college students and I presume
College professors call themselves
professors usually not teachers even
though they certainly are teachers and
they do teach I presume that you're
teaching younger students than that
um and
even though it's a very important
activity we get very little training in
it right we're not very reflective about
how best to do it and not even just to
the explicit teaching part but the
guidance the supervision the advising of
things that are tangential to or
completely outside the classroom so
things like how to inculcate and
encourage humility or growth mindset or
something like that I really don't have
any explicit advice I think the one
thing I can say not very helpful but the
one thing I can say is exemplify those
virtues if you want students to get them
themselves like they're hard to train
like you you sort of have to hope that
the student already wants to be humble
if they don't want to be humble it's
very hard to get them to be humble but
if they want to be you can help them
move in that direction like you can want
to be humble but not succeed right or
you can want to have a growth mindset
and and not have it and but then at
least maybe you'll put some effort into
trying and in those cases just see it
done is as valuable as anything else I
can think of when you're standing up in
front of the class
show some humility right like be clear
when you don't understand something when
you've made a mistake all of these
things it's a tricky thing to do because
you also need you know some respect some
level of authority uh you don't want the
students to completely distrust
everything you say but you want them to
realize that you can make mistakes and I
like to think that they trust you more
when you're honest about your mistakes
and you let your curiosity shine through
you know you make it clear that you're
not studying or talking or teaching
about this particular thing because
you're supposed to or you have to but
you're truly passionate and excited
about it and that's hard to fake if you
actually are they will get it you know
they're watching you for hours on end
and they pick up all these little things
that you don't even think that they're
noticing that's what students do so uh
but beyond that yeah I'm sorry I don't
have any specific suggestions uh I do
think it's an interesting thing to think
about but someone who's a professional
at being a good educator would be a
better person to ask than me
Paul proudlock says I've now attended
both Brian greens and Brian Cox's
science physics public presentations to
Great Delight while listening to
Professor Green last night duronto I
could carolyze his presentation some by
adding the ways you have taught special
and general relativity and of course
inserted the many worlds interpretation
were appropriate have you considered
putting on such a presentation and
touring it
you know roughly speaking no I'm very
glad that they do it you know Brian both
Brian's Brian Greene and Brian Cox are
friends of mine who are enormously
successful
popularizers of Science and physics and
so I don't know if everyone out there
knows but I don't even know about Brian
Greene's stuff particularly but Brian
Cox in the UK really has uh perfected a
show that is not just a lecture it's not
just you know he gets up there and talks
about you know like I do like I get up
there with my PowerPoints that I made
the previous night and talk to people I
do that all the time but uh
this is a whole different level of thing
with high production values everything
really thought out uh Vivid Graphics
computer generated stuff music you know
a whole thing that keeps people
entertained and is really at the same
time actually educational
um doing that
it's a lot of work right it's a
tremendous amount of work and I
absolutely think it's valuable and I'm
really really glad that they do it
um it's just something that I've chosen
not to do and also probably would fail
because the thing about both of those is
you have to kind of be famous before you
do them and I know that you all know me
because you're listening to the AMA
you're like at hour three in the AMA for
the mindscape podcast but I do not have
uh the public recognition that either
one of those Brians do so if I did put
enormous amount of work into something
like that and you know booked a 300 seat
Auditorium and had 15 people in it uh
that would be discouraging for me so it
is again I guess the theme of this AMA
is uh
satisficing our desires under conditions
of finite resources right I you know
that something like that would be fun
but given the resources I have and the
other things I want to do writing books
doing the podcast doing research in
physics and philosophy teaching my
courses all of these things
um I don't have time to do that you know
when people say they don't have time to
do something they don't really mean they
don't have time they mean I am not
prioritizing it as high as I am the
other things that I want to do with my
time so that's the right thing to say I
do not prioritize trying to do something
like that as much as I do other things
with my time am I making the right
choices with my priorities who knows but
I'm having fun for the moment even
though I have a little bit too many
things that I've agreed to do
okay
the very last question of today's AMA
comes from Johann Falk who says I think
it was when listening to episode 206
with Simon Conway Morris on Evolution
that you concluded that we only have a
sample size of one when it comes to
determining how often life evolves into
civilization level life
then it occurred to me couldn't we for
all effective purposes say that life in
the ocean and life on land evolved
separately where it comes to chances of
reaching civilization level life there
are of course interactions between the
two biospheres but in many aspects they
are separate when it comes to evolving
intelligent life so if I'm right then we
have at least a sample size of two do
you agree
well I guess so there's I realized only
after
reading this question a couple times
that
um it depends on even by your sample
size is your sample size the successful
achievements of civilization level life
or every appearance of life right I mean
we have a sample size of no civilization
level life appeared on the moon
so that's part is that part of the
sample I think that what I meant was you
know the sample size of just successful
appearances of civilizations and in that
case I would not count the ocean I don't
think there's any civilizations in the
sea that are different than the ones on
land but also those two ecosystems are
super duper intertwined with each other
I don't think it's actually fair in any
ways to think of them as separate for
these kinds of questions for one thing
there is a last Universal common
ancestor if you go back in biological
time both the living beings that we know
of in the sea and on the land came from
a common ancestor
but even much more recently than that
there is a give and take human beings
and other land animals often eat seafood
right uh we have an enormous impact on
the Ecology of what goes on in the
oceans Etc even back before we started
dumping trash and fossil fuels into the
biosphere that was still something the
human beings still had a big impact so
and and by the way you know to make
things a little bit more concrete one
successful development of civilization
could easily crowd out all other
possibilities like people often ask is
it evidence that life is difficult to
evolve that we do have a universal
common ancestor that there are not 15
different examples of Life independently
starting here on Earth I don't think
that's much evidence for every anything
because there are ecological niches and
whoever starts first is likely to win
right I think that the actual life that
started is more or less likely to spread
to all the niches it can find and life
that started later even if it's separate
would have a tough time competing with
that and civilizations might be exactly
the same way so once you're on the same
planet
I think that by my standards you can
only count one development of a
civilization per Planet as part of our
sample size so I still don't know how
likely it is that uh life evolves into
technologically advanced civilizations
or not these are fun things to think
about maybe someday even before too long
we will have a much larger sample size
than that and with that thought thanks
for listening to the AMA have a good
month and thanks very very much for
supporting mindscape I really appreciate
it
[Music]
la la